programming throwdown episode 165 differential equations take it away jason hey everybody um this is going to be a cool show we're going to talk about something that patrick and i are definitely not experts in but i've had to do a lot of it recently and i think it's very important and so we're going to talk about diff eq um oh man you already shortened it i'm already out you know i don't know if uh did we have to take diffiffie Q in college? I did. Was it a requirement?
programming throwdown episode 165 differential equations take it away jason hey everybody um this is going to be a cool show we're going to talk about something that patrick and i are definitely not experts in but i've had to do a lot of it recently and i think it's very important and so we're going to talk about diff eq um oh man you already shortened it i'm already out you know i don't know if uh did we have to take diffiffie Q in college? I did. Was it a requirement?|||programming throwdown 第 165 期，微分方程，杰森，你来吧。嗨，大家好，嗯，这将是一个很酷的节目。我们要聊一个我和帕特里克绝对不是专家的话题，但我最近经常需要用到，而且我觉得它非常重要，所以我们要聊聊微分方程。哦，天哪，你已经把它简写了，我都还没听就想退出了。你知道，我不知道，我们在大学里必须学微分方程吗？我学过。这是必修课吗？
It was a requirement. I did very, very bad at it. You know, I honestly don't even remember taking it. So that goes to say, show something right there. I don't know if I took it or not, but we are going to dive deep into it. It turns out it is really important. And so we'll get to that. But before we do, I want to talk about spreadsheets. I actually fell back in love with Excel, in this case, Google Sheets. But we really take it for granted. I mean,
It was a requirement. I did very, very bad at it. You know, I honestly don't even remember taking it. So that goes to say, show something right there. I don't know if I took it or not, but we are going to dive deep into it. It turns out it is really important. And so we'll get to that. But before we do, I want to talk about spreadsheets. I actually fell back in love with Excel, in this case, Google Sheets. But we really take it for granted. I mean,|||这是必修课。我当时学得非常非常差。你知道，说实话，我甚至都不记得自己学过它。所以这就说明问题了。我不知道自己到底有没有学过，但我们接下来要深入探讨它。事实证明它真的很重要。所以我们会讲到这个。但在那之前，我想聊聊电子表格。我其实又重新爱上了 Excel，在这个例子中是谷歌表格。但我们真的把它们当作理所当然的东西了。我是说，
sometimes we even make fun of people who do tons of things in Excel. We say like, oh, we could have done so much of this in python or r or what have you but um you know one of the really powerful things in excel is the sort of like recursive nature of it and how you can kind of incrementally build on top of um some data and you can see all the intermediate values as long as you don't make the functions too complicated. So I had this thing where it's actually, it's kind of, it's pretty nerdy,
sometimes we even make fun of people who do tons of things in Excel. We say like, oh, we could have done so much of this in python or r or what have you but um you know one of the really powerful things in excel is the sort of like recursive nature of it and how you can kind of incrementally build on top of um some data and you can see all the intermediate values as long as you don't make the functions too complicated. So I had this thing where it's actually, it's kind of, it's pretty nerdy,|||有时候我们甚至会嘲笑那些在 Excel 里做大量事情的人。我们会说，哦，我们本来可以用 Python、R 或其他什么语言做很多这样的事情。但，你知道，Excel 非常强大的一点在于它的某种递归性质，以及你如何在某些数据之上逐步构建，而且只要你不把函数搞得太复杂，你就能看到所有的中间值。所以我遇到了这样一件事，其实它挺极客的，
but there's this video game called X4. And in X4, it's one of these grand strategy games. So you mine ore ore use ore to like make solar arrays and solar arrays give you energy and you can use the energy in the ore to make spaceships and anyway it goes on forever and i thought someone posted a google sheet of all the different resources and some stats on them and uh for the resources that you know require you to build things like solar arrays you know what are the ingredients okay so i had this google sheet as you know material um the cost to acquire it if it's some raw material
but there's this video game called X4. And in X4, it's one of these grand strategy games. So you mine ore ore use ore to like make solar arrays and solar arrays give you energy and you can use the energy in the ore to make spaceships and anyway it goes on forever and i thought someone posted a google sheet of all the different resources and some stats on them and uh for the resources that you know require you to build things like solar arrays you know what are the ingredients okay so i had this google sheet as you know material um the cost to acquire it if it's some raw material|||有一款电子游戏叫《X4：基石》。在《X4》中，这是一款宏大战略游戏。所以你开采矿石，或者用矿石来制造太阳能电池阵列，太阳能电池阵列为你提供能量，你可以利用能量和矿石来制造飞船，总之这没完没了。我想有人发布了一个谷歌表格，里面列出了所有不同的资源以及它们的一些统计数据。嗯，对于那些你知道需要建造太阳能电池阵列等东西的资源，你知道原料是什么吗？好吧，我有了这个谷歌表格作为，你知道的，材料，如果是某种原材料的话，获取它的成本，
or if it's not a raw material the time to build it and then all the requirements right and so um using some excel functions i was able to like recursively figure out the time it takes the total time it takes to get any ingredient so it's like the time it takes to build that thing, plus the time it takes to build all of its components, you know, times however many of those you need. So a solar array, it takes 60 seconds at your base time, plus, you know, it needs 10 of this other product. So whatever the total cumulative time is of the other product times 10 plus this plus this, right? And so that other product depends on other products and so it's this recursive thing but you know because i just specify and we talked about recursion in a couple of shows ago what was a pretty good tie-in um so you know because i just put this recursive step in and then i just control dragged you know
or if it's not a raw material the time to build it and then all the requirements right and so um using some excel functions i was able to like recursively figure out the time it takes the total time it takes to get any ingredient so it's like the time it takes that thing, plus the time it takes to build all of its components, you know, times however many of those you need. So a solar array, it takes 60 seconds at your base time, plus, you know, it needs 10 of this other product. So whatever the total cumulative time is of the other product times 10 plus this plus this, right? And so that other product depends on other products and so it's this recursive thing but you know because i just specify and we talked about recursion in a couple of shows ago what was a pretty good tie-in um so you know because i just put this recursive step in and then i just control dragged you://|||或者如果它不是原材料，则是建造它所需的时间，然后是所有的需求，对吧？所以，通过使用一些 Excel 函数，我能够递归地计算出获取任何原料所需的时间，也就是获取该物品所需的时间，加上建造其所有组件所需的时间，乘以你所需数量。所以一个太阳能电池阵列，基础时间需要 60 秒，另外，你知道的，它需要 10 个其他产品。所以其他产品的总累积时间乘以 10 加上这个再加上那个，对吧？因此那个其他产品又取决于其他产品，所以这是一个递归的东西，但是你知道，因为我刚刚指定了——我们在前几期的节目中谈到过递归，这真是一个很好的切入点——所以你知道，因为我把这个递归步骤放进去，然后我直接按住 Ctrl 键拖拽，你知道的，
that equation onto every row and excel like instantly figured it all out and said oh for you to build you know medium-sized battle cruiser it actually takes like 18 000 seconds or something you know including all the other things you have to build and then you cried because you had already done it twice yeah i mean it's it's uh it was so you know what what what it made me think about is like that that's really cool you know like i just specified this simple recursive step and then excel you know handles like not calling the function too many times and and caching the values it kind of did all of it for me and i wonder if like a python library that does something like that would be really useful like some extension
that equation onto every row and excel like instantly figured it all out and said oh for you to build you know medium-sized battle cruiser it actually takes like 18 000 seconds or something you know including all the other things you have to build and then you cried because you had already done it twice yeah i mean it's it's uh it was so you know what what what it made me think about is like that that's really cool you know like i just specified this simple recursive step and then excel you know handles like not calling the function too many times and and caching the values it kind of did all of it for me and i wonder if like a python library that does something like that would be really useful like some extension|||把那个公式应用到每一行，Excel 就像瞬间搞定了一样，说：“哦，如果你要建造一艘中型战列巡洋舰，实际上需要大约 18,000 秒左右，你知道的，包括你必须建造的所有其他东西。”然后你哭了，因为你之前已经手动算过两次了。是的，我是说，这真是太……你知道的，它让我想到的是，这真的很酷，你知道，我只是指定了这个简单的递归步骤，然后 Excel 就能处理好诸如不让函数被调用太多次以及缓存值之类的事情，它几乎把所有事情都为我做好了。我在想，如果有一个像这样的 Python 库会非常有用，比如某种扩展，
to numpy or something where in certain values in the array you could put equations and and then python would just do what excel does like it would just figure it all out for you yeah i ran into something not as complex as what you were doing but we were talking about index investing a bit uh two episodes ago again oh man look at us tying it in good us yeah look at this the but i had this thing where you know some time goes by and then you want to put some more money in but you want to rebalance what's there? So the idea of rebalancing is you have some target. I want the most common, you know, one that gets toted about is 60% stock and 40% bonds, you know, go read up on that. I'm not actually advising you to do that, but let's say you want to do that. So you have some index that is your stock allocation and some that is your bond. And let's just say you have two for simplicity.
to numpy or something where in certain values in the array you could put equations and and then python would just do what excel does like it would just figure it all out for you yeah i ran into something not as complex as what you were doing but we were talking about index investing a bit uh two episodes ago again oh man look at us tying it in good us yeah look at this the but i had this thing where you know some time goes by and then you want to put some more money in but you want to rebalance what's there? So the idea of rebalancing is you have some target. I want the most common, you know, one that gets toted about is 60% stock and 40% bonds, you know, go read up on that. I'm not actually advising you to do that, but let's say you want to do that. So you have some index that is your stock allocation and some that is your bond. And let's just say you have two for simplicity.|||比如针对 NumPy 的扩展，你可以在数组的某些值中放入方程，然后 Python 就会做 Excel 所做的事，也就是为你把这一切都计算出来。是的，我遇到了一件事，虽然没有你做的那样复杂，但我们在两期节目之前刚聊过一点指数投资。哦，天哪，看看我们把它们联系在一起了，我们真棒。是的，看看这个，但我遇到了这样一件事：一段时间过去了，你想再投入一些钱，但你想对现有的资产进行再平衡？所以再平衡的想法是，你有一些目标。我想要最常见的目标，你知道的，大家经常吹捧的是 60% 的股票和 40% 的债券，你可以去读读相关文章。我其实并不是在建议你这么做，但假设你想这么做。所以你有一些代表股票配置的指数和一些代表债券的指数。为了简单起见，我们就假设有两个。
Then over time, one goes up and one goes down or both go up, and you want to get back to your, you know, 6040 target. But you also want to bring in some new money. So could you run this on a calculator for two? Yeah, it's really not that bad. But just dropping them in a in this case, I think Excel has extensions to do it, but I was doing it in the Google version, Google Sheets, and they have a, you know, go get the latest stock price. So as long as if I updated it each time I do it, then it knows how many shares I have. So it'll tell me the new price, I say how much money I want to put in, and then it basically calculates my trades for me. And if I want to, for instance, like disallow selling, like I don't want to sell something, I just want to buy new, then you know, you can do
Then over time, one goes up and one goes down or both go up, and you want to get back to your, you know, 6040 target. But you also want to bring in some new money. So could you run this on a calculator for two? Yeah, it's really not that bad. But just dropping them in a in this case, I think Excel has extensions to do it, but I was doing it in the Google version, Google Sheets, and they have a, you know, go get the latest stock price. So as long as if I updated it each time I do it, then it knows how many shares I have. So it'll tell me the new price, I say how much money I want to put in, and then it basically calculates my trades for me. And if I want to, for instance, like disallow selling, like I don't want to sell something, I just want to buy new, then you know, you can do|||然后随着时间的推移，一个上涨，一个下跌，或者两个都上涨，你想回到你那 60/40 的目标。但你也想引入一些新的资金。所以你能用计算器为两个资产计算这个吗？是的，其实并不算太糟。但把它们放进——在这种情况下，我认为 Excel 有扩展程序可以做到这一点，但我使用的是谷歌版本，即 Google Sheets，它们有一个功能，可以去获取最新的股票价格。所以只要我每次操作时都更新它，它就知道我有多少股。然后它会告诉我新的价格，我说我想投入多少钱，接着它基本上就为我计算好了交易。如果我想，比如，不允许卖出——就像我不想卖掉某些东西，只想买入新的——那么，你知道，你可以通过条件逻辑来做到这一点。
that with the conditional logic. And sort of like you you're saying you iterate back on it and sort of you know step on it do not even iterations but just one column to the next where you're sort of rolling for your computations and it was just like oh because it turns out it wasn't doing it with two i was doing with like five uh five different indexes and so you know this is so much nicer to like set it up once and then be able to just rerun it if i had sat down in python i know there's an api for pulling down stock prices i know i could have put my stuff in a you know csv or a json and then read it in and done it but i i'm not clear that i wanted additional flexibility i'm you know i'm not trying to
that with the conditional logic. And sort of like you you're saying you iterate back on it and sort of you know step on it do not even iterations but just one column to the next where you're sort of rolling for your computations and it was just like oh because it turns out it wasn't doing it with two i was doing with like five uh five different indexes and so you know this is so much nicer to like set it up once and then be able to just rerun it if i had sat down in python i know there's an api for pulling down stock prices i know i could have put my stuff in a you know csv or a json and then read it in and done it but i i'm not clear that i wanted additional flexibility i'm you know i'm not trying to|||就像你刚才说的，你对此进行迭代，或者说——甚至都不是迭代，只是从一列到下一列，你的计算在不断滚动。这感觉就像——哦，因为事实证明它处理的不是两个，我处理的是大约五个，五个不同的指数。所以，你知道，这好太多了，只需要设置一次，然后就能随时重新运行。如果我坐在 Python 前面，我知道有获取股票价格的 API，我知道我可以把我的东西放进 CSV 或 JSON 中，然后读取并完成它，但我并不清楚自己是否需要额外的灵活性。我，你知道的，我并不是想为所有人或每种情况解决这个问题，这也不是我的工作。我只是想要一个快速的解决方案。
solve this for every person or every case this isn isn't my job. I just wanted a quick solution. But I will agree with you that my hobby horses on this are people don't want to learn SQL. And we talked about that before on the show. But I think people don't like to learn spreadsheets. There's a group of people who just don't know how to run Excel or Sheets. And they don't know how to get graphs really easily. And they say, oh, it's OK. I do it in Python.
solve this for every person or every case this isn isn't my job. I just wanted a quick solution. But I will agree with you that my hobby horses on this are people don't want to learn SQL. And we talked about that before on the show. But I think people don't like to learn spreadsheets. There's a group of people who just don't know how to run Excel or Sheets. And they don't know how to get graphs really easily. And they say, oh, it's OK. I do it in Python.|||不过我同意你的看法，我在这方面一直有个执念，那就是人们不想学 SQL。我们在节目中以前讨论过这个。但我认为人们也不喜欢学电子表格。有一群人就是不知道怎么运行 Excel 或 Google Sheets。而且他们不知道怎么非常轻松地获取图表。他们会说，哦，没关系，我用 Python 做。
It's like, but I sort of guarantee if you only make this chart once or only for one thing you know doing it first in the spreadsheet and then if you go to do it again fine i'll give it to you that the second time you have to do it you can do it in python but that first time you almost guaranteed if you know what you're doing you're going to get it faster in the spreadsheet just dumping out some output you know new line separated dump from your program and then you can copy paste that into Excel and get your plot much, much, much quicker. Yep. Yeah, totally. And in your case, you're talking about balancing. So, you know, if you had a certain allocation, you know, a certain state, then you know, like how much of something to buy or sell to get you to equilibrium right so you have actually
It's like, but I sort of guarantee if you only make this chart once or only for one thing you know doing it first in the spreadsheet and then if you go to do it again fine i'll give it to you that the second time you have to do it you can do it in python but that first time you almost guaranteed if you know what you're doing you're going to get it faster in the spreadsheet just dumping out some output you know new line separated dump from your program and then you can copy paste that into Excel and get your plot much, much, much quicker. Yep. Yeah, totally. And in your case, you're talking about balancing. So, you know, if you had a certain allocation, you know, a certain state, then you know, like how much of something to buy or sell to get you to equilibrium right so you have actually|||就像是，但我敢保证，如果你只制作一次这个图表，或者只为一件事制作，你知道，先在电子表格里做，然后如果你非要做第二次，好吧，我承认第二次你可以用 Python 做。但第一次，如果你知道自己在做什么，几乎可以肯定你在电子表格里会做得更快——只需从你的程序中导出一些输出（你知道的，用新行分隔的转储），然后你可以把它们复制粘贴到 Excel 中，就能快得多、多、多地得到你的图表。是的。完全同意。而在你的例子中，你谈到了平衡。所以，你知道，如果你有一定的资产配置，你知道，某种状态，然后你知道，应该买入或卖出多少某种资产才能让你达到平衡，对吧？所以你实际上拥有一个微分方程，
a differential equation you have an equation that says here's how i get from where i am to where i want to be but then if you take a really large step there you might end up buying like way too many bonds and then you're unstable or something okay well before we get into that we will uh two episodes ago in our duo we were talking about the buzz and excitement of lk99 yeah and uh feels it feels like the what is the meme it's back and then it's over and it's back uh and uh if you if you followed it on x i'm just gonna go with twitter if you followed on twitter at all you saw these memes go by but um you know i it seems that a lot of people who sort of bided their time and really thought through it and did some analysis are pretty
a differential equation you have an equation that says here's how i get from where i am to where i want to be but then if you take a really large step there you might end up buying like way too many bonds and then you're unstable or something okay well before we get into that we will uh two episodes ago in our duo we were talking about the buzz and excitement of lk99 yeah and uh feels it feels like the what is the meme it's back and then it's over and it's back uh and uh if you if you followed it on x i'm just gonna go with twitter if you followed on twitter at all you saw these memes go by but um you know i it seems that a lot of people who sort of bided their time and really thought through it and did some analysis are pretty|||你有一个方程，它表达的是：这就是我如何从当前位置到达我想去的位置的方法。但如果你在那里迈出了非常大的一步，你最终可能会买入过多的债券，然后你就会变得不稳定或怎样。好吧，在我们深入讨论这个之前，两期节目以前，我们俩曾讨论过关于 LK-99 的热潮和兴奋感。是的，感觉……感觉就像那个梗——它回来了，然后又结束了，然后它又回来了。而且，如果你在 X（我还是叫它 Twitter 吧）上关注过这件事，如果你在 Twitter 上关注过，你就会看到这些梗刷屏。但是，你知道，似乎许多花时间等待、真正深入思考并做了一些分析的人都相当确信，
convinced that at least at this point there's no evidence yet that that lk99 is is a superconductor so there's a nature article now out sort of saying this and some sort of well more well-reviewed stuff is out people are that the aftermath is somewhat interesting there's still some studying to be done of the material which you know happened but then there's it's it's very divisive i'm not a scientific scientist by trade or even a scientist period i guess um but there seems to be a big divide between was this a okay thing that it happened this way the original article was a pre-print right so it wasn't actually in a peer-reviewed journal it was just a pre-print
convinced that at least at this point there's no evidence yet that that lk99 is is a superconductor so there's a nature article now out sort of saying this and some sort of well more well-reviewed stuff is out people are that the aftermath is somewhat interesting there's still some studying to be done of the material which you know happened but then there's it's it's very divisive i'm not a scientific scientist by trade or even a scientist period i guess um but there seems to be a big divide between was this a okay thing that it happened this way the original article was a pre-print right so it wasn't actually in a peer-reviewed journal it was just a pre-print|||至少在目前，还没有证据表明 LK-99 是超导体。所以现在有一篇《自然》杂志的文章出来阐述了这一点，还有一些经过更严格同行评议的内容也发表了。人们觉得后续事件相当有趣，这种材料仍然有一些研究要做（这是显而易见的），但随后……这非常有争议。我职业上不是科学家，甚至算不上什么科学家，我想，但这里似乎存在着巨大的分歧：以这种方式发生这件事是一件可以接受的事情吗？最初的文章是一篇预印本，对吧？所以它实际上并非发表在同行评议的期刊上，而只是一篇预印本，
that everyone got excited about was this a waste of resources and you know does someone lose reputation or is this yeah this is just a more open, involved, broader scientific community and hobbyist sort of thing. I'll say from the sidelines, that's the most excitement I had had about material science in a preprint article ever. And I learned a lot. Clearly, there was a lot of speculation going on that we talked about a little last time. People saying things that just weren't going to happen or weren't true uh even if it had been everything it promised but yeah so what like you know i i don't i don't personally see what was harmed if people decided to try to pursue replicating this using resources that they otherwise shouldn't
that everyone got excited about was this a waste of resources and you know does someone lose reputation or is this yeah this is just a more open, involved, broader scientific community and hobbyist sort of thing. I'll say from the sidelines, that's the most excitement I had had about material science in a preprint article ever. And I learned a lot. Clearly, there was a lot of speculation going on that we talked about a little last time. People saying things that just weren't going to happen or weren't true uh even if it had been everything it promised but yeah so what like you know i i don't i don't personally see what was harmed if people decided to try to pursue replicating this using resources that they otherwise shouldn't|||让所有人都兴奋不已。这是一种资源浪费吗？你知道，是否有人因此声誉受损？或者说——是的，这只是一种更加开放、参与度更高、更广泛的科学界和爱好者的现象。作为局外人，我想说，那是我有生以来对预印本文章中的材料科学感到最兴奋的一次。我学到了很多东西。很明显，当时有很多猜测，我们上次也稍微谈到过。人们说的一些事情根本不可能发生，或者根本不是真的——即使它完全兑现了所有的承诺。但是，好吧，那又怎样？就像，你知道，我个人看不出如果人们决定利用本不该用于此目的的资源去尝试复现它，究竟有什么被损害了。
have i feel like that's a that's a game theoretical decision that they made uh and it's it's sort of case by case so i i don't i don't sort of hold the broader community but again not my my domain so it's possible that i'm missing some part of the equation there yeah i mean i think that that uh it's a good question you i have a couple of things here one is i've seen some people say that okay it's not a super conductor but it's still important because it you know important because it's like a better conductor and there's certain things that we learned because of it. And so it seems like it is some kind of incremental step forward. The other part of it is, you know, there's definitely like a outrage economy. And so, you know, I think on things like Twitter,
have i feel like that's a that's a game theoretical decision that they made uh and it's it's sort of case by case so i i don't i don't sort of hold the broader community but again not my my domain so it's possible that i'm missing some part of the equation there yeah i mean i think that that uh it's a good question you i have a couple of things here one is i've seen some people say that okay it's not a super conductor but it's still important because it you know important because it's like a better conductor and there's certain things that we learned because of it. And so it seems like it is some kind of incremental step forward. The other part of it is, you know, there's definitely like a outrage economy. And so, you know, I think on things like Twitter,|||我觉得那是他们做出的博弈论决策，而且这因情况而异，所以我不会把这归咎于更广泛的科学界。但话说回来，这也不是我的领域，所以我可能漏掉了其中的一部分。是的，我的意思是，我认为这是一个好问题。我这里有几点看法：第一，我看到有人说，好吧，它不是超导体，但它依然很重要，因为它（你知道的）很重要，因为它就像是一个更好的导体，而且我们由于它学到了一些特定的东西。所以它似乎算是一种渐进式的向前迈进。另一部分是，你知道，这绝对存在一种“愤怒经济”。所以，你知道，我认为在像 Twitter 这样的平台上，
you know, like a lot of people probably got a lot of followers for being, you know, really passionate about it. And so that's a really big, big problem, I think, that, you know, it's hard to overcome. Do you know if they know if they're still, like, is that material useful, even if it's not a superconductor?
you know, like a lot of people probably got a lot of followers for being, you know, really passionate about it. And so that's a really big, big problem, I think, that, you6 know, it's hard to overcome. Do you know if they know if they're still, like, is that material useful, even if it's not a superconductor?|||你知道的，很多人可能因为对此表现得非常热情而获得了大量的粉丝。所以我认为这是一个非常非常大的问题，很难克服。你知道他们是否知道——这种材料即使不是超导体，它还有用吗？
Yeah, I think some people think it might be interesting, but once the hubbub has sort of died, I think a lot of people became a little more soft-spoken about things. Yeah, right. Like anything anything once it becomes more subtle right the you know it it's a little harder for people outside to maybe understand the implications i expect people will still continue some amount of studying down this
Yeah, I think some people think it might be interesting, but once the hubbub has sort of died, I think a lot of people became a little more soft-spoken about things. Yeah, right. Like anything anything once it becomes more subtle right the you know it it's a little harder for people outside to maybe understand the implications i expect people will still continue some amount of studying down this|||是的，我想有些人认为它可能很有趣，但一旦喧嚣平息下来，我认为很多人对事情的看法变得更加温和了。是的，没错。就像任何事情一样，一旦变得更加微妙，你知道，局外人可能就更难理解其含义了。我预计人们仍会继续沿着这个方向进行一定程度的研究。
avenue um it seems like there's some novel properties but yeah i think the unlock of a actual room temperature and to be clear it's room temperature and room pressure like you know sort of normal atmospheric pressure um the the two thing missing either one of those sort of makes it just not the step function of a new discovery so even if it's still a superconductor at low temperature which isn't clear that like it could be a a massive improvement but not getting to where we are you know where the speculation was going sort of a letdown and maybe that's where people are pointing out is because it's a letdown of the public then the public loses faith in the in the process yeah that makes sense um my article is on normalizing flows have you ever heard of this i know this these words in individually in many contexts but i do not know what this is about
avenue um it seems like there's some novel properties but yeah i think the unlock of a actual room temperature and to be clear it's room temperature and room pressure like you know sort of normal atmospheric pressure um the the two thing missing either one of those sort of makes it just not the step function of a new discovery so even if it's still a superconductor at low temperature which isn't clear that like it could be a a massive improvement but not getting to where we are you know where the speculation was going sort of a letdown and maybe that's where people are pointing out is because it's a letdown of the public then the public loses faith in the in the process yeah that makes sense um my article is on normalizing flows have you ever heard of this i know this these words in individually in many contexts but i do not know what this is about|||嗯，它似乎有一些新奇的特性。但是，是的，我认为解锁真正的室温——需要明确的是，是室温和室压，就像正常的大气压一样——这两点中只要缺了其中任何一点，就会让它失去新发现的阶跃函数般的意义。所以，即使它在低温下仍然是超导体（这一点目前还不清楚），虽然这可能是一个巨大的改进，但没有达到我们——你知道的——人们猜测的高度，这就有点让人失望了。也许这就是人们所指出的：因为这让公众感到失望，所以公众对整个过程失去了信心。嗯，这说得通。我的文章是关于“归一化流”（normalizing flows）的。你听说过这个吗？我在许多语境下分别听过这些词，但我不知道这是关于什么的。
all right so i'll explain so um we have you know in in random math right we have probability density functions right and so what this means is you know if in random math, right, we have probability density functions, right? And so what this means is, you know, if you look at like a coin, a coin has heads or tails, right? And so it has a 50-50 chance if it's a fair coin of being heads or tails. If you look at a die, you know, a die has one through six printed on it. And when you roll it, you know, if it's a fair die, you have an equal chance of getting one through six, right? Well,
all right so i'll explain so um we have you know in in random math right we have probability density functions right and so what this means is you know if in random math, right, we have probability density functions, right? And so what this means is, you know, if you look at like a coin, a coin has heads or tails, right? And so it has a 50-50 chance if it's a fair coin of being heads or tails. If you look at a die, you know, a die has one through six printed on it. And when you roll it, you know, if it's a fair die, you have an equal chance of getting one through six, right? Well,|||好吧，那我来解释一下。所以，我们在随机数学中，对吧，我们有概率密度函数，对吧？这意味着什么呢？如果你看一枚硬币，硬币有正面或反面，对吧？如果是一枚匀质硬币，它出现正面或反面的几率是 50 对 50。如果你看一个骰子，你知道，骰子上面印着 1 到 6 的数字。当你投掷它时，如果是一个匀质骰子，你得到 1 到 6 的几率是相等的，对吧？那么，
how do you do this with random numbers? And so the random numbers, you do it through probability density functions, which are like actually really non-intuitive. Maybe like a good example is like voltage coming into your house. So, you know, you have this vault meter and it measures the voltage, a multimeter, and it measures the voltage coming into your house, and it says 120. But it's not like exactly 120, or like exactly this number of electrons past the multimeter, it's some kind of rolling average of some, know estimate and so if you were to like dive into the multimeter it's probably
how do you do this with random numbers? And so the random numbers, you do it through probability density functions, which are like actually really non-intuitive. Maybe like a good example is like voltage coming into your house. So, you know, you have this vault meter and it measures the voltage, a multimeter, and it measures the voltage coming into your house, and it says 120. But it's not like exactly 120, or like exactly this number of electrons past the multimeter, it's some kind of rolling average of some, know estimate and so if you were to like dive into the multimeter it's probably|||你如何在随机数中做到这一点呢？对于随机数，你是通过概率密度函数来实现的，这实际上非常不符合直觉。也许一个很好的例子就是进入你家里的电压。所以，你知道，你有一个电压表，它测量电压，一个万用表，它测量进入你家里的电压，上面显示 120。但它并不是精确的 120，也不是精确数量的电子流过万用表，而是某种估计值的滚动平均值。所以如果你深入探究万用表内部，它可能
getting 119 121 you know and these are going to be floating point numbers like 119.x 120.y right and it's averaging them out and saying 120 um and so what you really have in your house, the voltage in your house is going to be some density function where the mean is 120 and then it has some tails. Like sometimes when you read it, you get numbers that are greater or less than 120. Right. Does that make sense? Yep. Okay. So it turns out, you know, if you have an expected value and there's just some error on either side, you know, normal distribution does a pretty good job.
getting 119 121 you know and these are going to be floating point numbers like 119.x 120.y right and it's averaging them out and saying 120 um and so what you really have in your house, the voltage in your house is going to be some density function where the mean is 120 and then it has some tails. Like sometimes when you read it, you get numbers that are greater or less than 120. Right. Does that make sense? Yep. Okay. So it turns out, you know, if you have an expected value and there's just some error on either side, you know, normal distribution does a pretty good job.|||得到的是 119、121，你知道的，这些将是浮点数，比如 119.x、120.y，对吧？它把它们平均起来，然后说这是 120。所以你家里实际拥有的，你家里的电压将是一个密度函数，其均值为 120，然后它有一些尾部。就像有时候你读数时，你会得到大于或小于 120 的数字。对吧。这说得通吗？是的。好的。事实证明，如果你有一个期望值，并且两边都有一些误差，那么正态分布在这方面做得相当不错。
And those are pretty easy to calculate. Right. What if you have a really weird thing? Like, for example, what if I have a data set that has American voltage data and European voltage data in the same data set so like you know half the numbers seem to be around 120 but then half the numbers seem to be around 230 and they're all just mixed together right so if you just fit a regular normal distribution to that you're gonna it's gonna tell you oh like almost all your voltages are around like 180 or something plus or minus some error which is not really representing what you
And those are pretty easy to calculate. Right. What if you have a really weird thing? Like, for example, what if I have a data set that has American voltage data and European voltage data in the same data set so like you know half the numbers seem to be around 120 but then half the numbers seem to be around 230 and they're all just mixed together right so if you just fit a regular normal distribution to that you're gonna it's gonna tell you oh like almost all your voltages are around like 180 or something plus or minus some error which is not really representing what you|||这些东西计算起来非常简单。对吧。如果你遇到一个非常奇怪的情况会怎么样？比如，如果我有一个数据集，里面既有美国的电压数据，又有欧洲的电压数据，在同一个数据集里，你知道的，其中一半的数字似乎在 120 左右，但另一半的数字似乎在 230 左右，它们就这样混在一起了，对吧？所以如果你只是对它拟合一个常规的正态分布，它会告诉你，哦，你的电压几乎都在 180 左右，正负一些误差，这并不能真正代表你
have what you actually have is what's called a bimodal distribution where you have one mode you have one cluster around 120 and you have another cluster around 230 um so you know what you want to do is you want to know the distribution of these kinds of data sets, right? These complicated data sets. And once you have the distribution, there's all sorts of interesting things you could do. Like, for example, you know, if you know the distribution of the voltage in your house, and let's say it's 120 plus or minus one volt right then if the voltage is like 130 or 150 you know like oh my house is really messed up like i like i'm gonna like my electronics are gonna start blowing up i need to do something about it right if you measure the voltage in
have what you actually have is what's called a bimodal distribution where you have one mode you have one cluster around 120 and you have another cluster around 230 um so you know what you want to do is you want to know the distribution of these kinds of data sets, right? These complicated data sets. And once you have the distribution, there's all sorts of interesting things you could do. Like, for example, you know, if you know the distribution of the voltage in your house, and let's say it's 120 plus or minus one volt right then if the voltage is like 130 or 150 you know like oh my house is really messed up like i like i'm gonna like my electronics are gonna start blowing up i need to do something about it right if you measure the voltage in|||实际拥有的情况。你实际拥有的是所谓的“双峰分布”（bimodal distribution），即你有一个众数，你有一个围绕 120 的集群，你还有另一个围绕 230 的集群。所以，你知道你想做什么吗？你想了解这类数据集的分布，对吧？这些复杂的数据集。一旦你有了这个分布，你就可以做各种有趣的事情。比如，你知道的，如果你知道你家里的电压分布，假设它是 120 伏正负 1 伏，对吧？那么如果电压是 130 伏或 150 伏，你知道的，就像“哦，我家真的出大问题了，我——我的电子设备要开始爆炸了，我得做点什么”，对吧？如果你测量的电压是
your house and it's like 120 plus or minus 20 volts and everything in your house is still working then you know like okay i have a pretty good tolerance for voltage in my house right um and so when you get to these really weird distributions you still want to know the same thing which is like have i seen something like this before and so to answer you know have I seen something like this before questions, you need to have a density function. You know, like how dense is this part of the system? How dense is this function? And so normalizing flows are a way to get like almost arbitrarily complex density functions so if you have really weird shapes that you know are are um you know that that you can't really categorize as with any normal density function you could always run
your house and it's like 120 plus or minus 20 volts and everything in your house is still working then you know like okay i have a pretty good tolerance for voltage in my house right um and so when you get to these really weird distributions you still want to know the same thing which is like have i seen something like this before and so to answer you know have I seen something like this before questions, you need to have a density function. You know, like how dense is this part of the system? How dense is this function? And so normalizing flows are a way to get like almost arbitrarily complex density functions so if you have really weird shapes that you know are are um you know that that you can't really categorize as with any normal density function you could always run|||你家里的电压，比如 120 伏正负 20 伏，而你家里的所有东西依然在正常工作，那么你就知道，“好吧，我家里对电压有相当好的耐受力”，对吧？嗯，所以当你遇到这些非常奇怪的分布时，你仍然想知道同一件事，那就是：“我以前见过类似的东西吗？”为了回答“我以前见过类似的东西吗”这样的问题，你需要有一个密度函数。你知道的，系统这一部分的密度有多大？这个函数的密度有多大？所以归一化流就是一种获得几乎任意复杂密度函数的方法，因此如果你有一些你知道是……嗯，你无法用任何普通密度函数对其进行归类的非常奇怪的形状，你总是可以运行
normalizing flows and it'll it'll learn that function for you um and so it's a bunch of really cool things you can do with something like this like i'll give you an example um you know there's these like breast cancer data sets right and and uh um they're pretty famous they came out of uh uc irvine and it's basically a whole bunch of data of like stats on on people and then i think there's maybe pictures mammogram pictures and then there's like whether there's a tumor or not. And, you know, you could train a classifier and say like, yes, breast cancer, no breast cancer. And there's a bunch of tutorials on how to do this on the internet. But, you know, you could use something like normalizing flows to say like, have I seen a candidate like this before? And if the answer is no,
normalizing flows and it'll it'll learn that function for you um and so it's a bunch of really cool things you can do with something like this like i'll give you an example um you know there's these like breast cancer data sets right and and uh um they're pretty famous they came out of uh uc irvine and it's basically a whole bunch of data of like stats on on people and then i think there's maybe pictures mammogram pictures and then there's like whether there's a tumor or not. And, you know, you could train a classifier and say like, yes, breast cancer, no breast cancer. And there's a bunch of tutorials on how to do this on the internet. But, you, you could use something like normalizing flows to say like, have I seen a candidate like this before? And if the answer is no,|||归一化流，它会为你学习那个函数。嗯，所以你可以用这样的东西做一堆非常酷的事情，比如我举个例子，嗯，你知道有乳腺癌数据集，对吧，它们挺有名的，来自加州大学欧文分校（UCI），它基本上是一大堆关于人们统计数据的数据，然后我想可能还有图片，乳腺钼靶 X 光片，然后还有是否有肿瘤。而且，你知道，你可以训练一个分类器，说：有乳腺癌，没有乳腺癌。互联网上有大量关于如何做到这一点的教程。但是，你可以使用像归一化流这样的东西来判断：“我以前见过这样的候选样本吗？”如果答案是否定的，
then maybe you don't trust the screening as much. So if the screening says cancer, but you've never really seen anyone like this who had all these qualities, then maybe you ran an additional test. But if it says cancer and you've seen like tons of people just like this and they were all cancer,
then maybe you don't trust the screening as much. So if the screening says cancer, but you've never really seen anyone like this who had all these qualities, then maybe you ran an additional test. But if it says cancer and you've seen like tons of people just like this and they were all cancer,|||那么你可能就不会那么信任筛查结果了。所以如果筛查结果显示是癌症，但你从未真正见过具备所有这些特质的类似患者，那么你可能会做一次额外的检测。但如果它显示是癌症，而你见过海量完全这样的人，并且他们最终都被确诊为癌症，
then you're much more like certain, right? And yeah, and so there's a whole rabbit hole there but check out the link it has a really good explanation of how to do this and um this uh is a relatively recent thing i mean it used to be that you would um take that normal distribution the one i explained before, and you do what's called mixtures. And so mixtures are good if like the example I gave or something's either 120 or 230. So if you had something that was either like one of several values just with some error, then that's fine. But if something's just like arbitrarily distributed like it's just like some weird shape there's not really any way to recover that um until some of these recent methods
then you're much more like certain, right? And yeah, and so there's a whole rabbit hole there but check out the link it has a really good explanation of how to do this and um this uh is a relatively recent thing i mean it used to be that you would um take that normal distribution the one i explained before, and you do what's called mixtures. And so mixtures are good if like the example I grade or something's either 120 or 230. So if you had something that was either like one of several values just with some error, then that's fine. But if something's just like arbitrarily distributed like it's just like some weird shape there's not really any way to recover that um until some of these recent methods|||那么你就会更有把握，对吧？是的，所以这其中有一个巨大的兔子洞（深奥的知识点），但去看看链接吧，里面对如何做到这一点有非常好的解释。而且，这相对来说是个较新的东西——我的意思是，过去你会采用那种正态分布（我之前解释过的那种），然后做所谓的“混合模型”（mixtures）。所以混合模型在以下情况下很好用：比如我刚才举的例子，某事物的取值要么是 120，要么是 230。所以如果你有一些东西，它的值是几个特定数值之一并带有一定误差，那么混合模型没问题。但如果某个东西是任意分布的，就像某种奇怪的形状，在这些最新方法出现之前，真的没有什么好办法来恢复它。
so i've been keeping an eye on it and it's they've been making tons of progress this isn't even the latest one it's just the one that i found the best explanation for that's relatively modern but i think that there's going to be a good future to these methods yeah this this is interesting i naively would have thought yeah i have come across this problem before i didn't know this was done this way and what i did is sort of you think about histogramming and then just taking the data you do have and sort of making i guess you would almost call it a discrete density function and just using the data you do have to estimate the percentages which of course
so i've been keeping an eye on it and it's they've been making tons of progress this isn't even the latest one it's just the one that i found the best explanation for that's relatively modern but i think that there's going to be a good future to these methods yeah this is interesting i naively would have thought yeah i have come across this problem before i didn't know this was done this way and what i did is sort of you think about histogramming and then just taking the data you do have and sort of making i guess you would almost call it a discrete density function and just using the data you do have to estimate the percentages which of course|||所以我一直在关注它，他们取得了大量的进展。这甚至都不是最新的方法，它只是我找到的解释得最好、相对较现代的方法，但我认为这些方法将有一个美好的未来。是的，这很有趣。我原本很天真地会想——是的，我以前遇到过这个问题，我不知道原来是这样处理的。而我的做法是，你会想到制作直方图，然后获取你拥有的数据，并将其制作成——我想你几乎可以称之为离散密度函数的东西，仅使用你拥有的数据来估计百分比，当然，
is difficult for things that once you've done the histogramming like things that come in between right but yeah there's there's some balance there but that's that's actually really interesting yeah i mean if you've ever built a heat map, I mean, that's basically a density function. And so this kind of takes it to the continuous space. Very cool. So my next one is probably going to require a bit of explanation, but it's how is Lama dot CPP possible? So Lama is and Jason, you're gonna have to help me if I get the background here wrong,
is difficult for things that once you've done the histogramming like things that come in between right but yeah there's there's some balance there but that's that's actually really interesting yeah i mean if you've ever built a heat map, I mean, that's basically a density function. And so this kind of takes it to the continuous space. Very cool. So my next one is probably going to require a bit of explanation, but it's how is Lama dot CPP possible? So Lama is and Jason, you're gonna have to help me if I get the background here wrong,|||对于那些一旦做了直方图之后处于中间状态的东西来说，这很困难，对吧？但是的，这其中有一些平衡，但那实际上真的很有趣。是的，我是说如果你曾经构建过热力图，我的意思是，那基本上就是一个密度函数。所以这种方法将其带入了连续空间。非常酷。所以我的下一个话题可能需要做一点解释，那就是：Llama.cpp 是怎么做到的？Llama 是——杰森，如果我把背景搞错了，你得帮帮我——
but Llama is one of the sort of chat GPT equivalents that came out of Facebook. And importantly, Facebook released the parameter weights as well as the architecture. And they just recently announced Llama 2. And there's sort of a debate around, is it open source? Is it not open
but Llama is one of the sort of chat GPT equivalents that came out of Facebook. And importantly, Facebook released the parameter weights as well as the architecture. And they just recently announced Llama 2. And there's sort of a debate around, is it open source? Is it not open|||但 Llama 是 Facebook 推出的类似于 ChatGPT 的替代品之一。重要的是，Facebook 不仅发布了架构，还发布了参数权重。他们最近刚刚宣布了 Llama 2。并且围绕着它是否是开源的，存在一些争论……它是不是开源的？
source uh they have some wording go read your go read the contract yourself the answer is for most people that aren't like a already established big company you can pretty much do whatever you want with it um and there has been a a person a group of people who had come out with this tool llama cpp which is basically uh implementing without uh i don't actually know i guess llama is in probably pi torch or something similar but without any of those frameworks from just sort of bare metal c++ implementing all of the required tensor operations and you know things that you need to do to take the weights and to take inputs and to get the expected outputs and the reason this is really interesting
source uh they have some wording go read your go read the contract yourself the answer is for most people that aren't like a already established big company you can pretty much do whatever you want with it um and there has been a a person a group of people who had come out with this tool llama cpp which is basically uh implementing without uh i don't actually know i guess llama is in probably pi torch or something similar but without any of those frameworks from just sort of bare metal c++ implementing all of the required tensor operations and you know things that you need to do to take the weights and to take inputs and to get the expected outputs and the reason this is really interesting|||——他们有一些措辞，去读读看吧，去自己读读合同。答案是，对于大多数不是那种已经站稳脚跟的大公司的人来说，你几乎可以用它做任何你想做的事。而且，曾有一个人或一群人推出了这个工具 Llama.cpp，它基本上是……在没有使用——我其实不太清楚，我猜 Llama 可能是在 PyTorch 或类似框架中运行的——但在没有任何这些框架的情况下，仅通过纯粹的裸机 C++ 实现了所有必需的张量运算，以及你知道的，为了接收权重、接收输入并获得预期输出所需要做的事情。而这之所以非常有趣，
is if you follow the space at all, the expectation of running Lama is that you do it on either some specific tensor hardware, like a TPU, or whatever, or more commonly on a very now expensive from a series of sort of circumstances, very expensive GPUs. And the biggest thing is you want to think about transferring the model weights to the GPUs memory. And then it allows all these operations to take take part very, very, very quickly. And this article sort of goes into this explanation that this is mostly about memory bandwidth, right? So the GPU has very expensive, very high bandwidth memory as well as discrete parallel processing units for doing all of the operations needed mama cpp doesn't benefit from you know sort of all of that gpu work what they are trying to do is using simd operations so it'd be like sse neon avx these kinds of things, which allow you to use your CPUs parallelization, but also using
is if you follow the space at all, the expectation of running Lama is that you do it on either some specific tensor hardware, like a TPU, or whatever, or more commonly on a very now expensive from a series of sort of circumstances, very expensive GPUs. And the biggest thing is you want to think about transferring the model weights to the GPUs memory. And then it allows all these operations to take take part very, very, very quickly. And this article sort of goes into this explanation that this is mostly about memory bandwidth, right? So the GPU has very expensive, very high bandwidth memory as well as discrete parallel processing units for doing all of the operations needed mama cpp doesn't benefit from you know sort of all of that gpu work what they are trying to do is using simd operations so it's like sse neon avx these kinds of things, which allow you to use your CPUs parallelization, but also using|||是因为如果你关注这个领域的话，运行 Llama 的预期是，你要么在某些特定的张量硬件上运行它（比如 TPU 或其他设备），要么更常见的是在一块因各种情况而变得非常昂贵的 GPU 上运行它。最主要的一点是，你需要考虑将模型权重传输到 GPU 的内存中。然后它允许所有这些操作非常、非常、非常快地进行。这篇文章大致解释了这一点，这主要关乎内存带宽，对吧？所以 GPU 拥有非常昂贵、非常高带宽的内存，以及用于执行所有必需操作的离散并行处理单元。Llama.cpp 并没有受益于所有这些 GPU 工作，他们试图做的是使用 SIMD（单指令多数据）操作，比如 SSE、Neon、AVX 这类技术，这允许你利用 CPU 的并行化，同时也使用了
the quantized model. So instead of floating point or double parameter weights, they do some retraining for a lot of these to get them down to four bits, or eight bits per parameter. And these have billions of parameters, I think most of them are like sort of like 12 billion parameters, right? So you're talking about a huge reduction in the amount of memory and then running them on just basically your CPU. Now, albeit a sort of accelerated thing, but the nice thing is you normally have a lot more memory
the quantized model. So instead of floating point or double parameter weights, they do some retraining for a lot of these to get them down to four bits, or eight bits per parameter. And these have billions of parameters, I think most of them are like sort of like 12 billion parameters, right? So you're talking about a huge reduction in the amount of memory and then running them on just basically your CPU. Now, albeit a sort of accelerated thing, but the nice thing is you normally have a lot more memory|||量化模型。因此，它们没有使用浮点或双精度参数权重，而是对其中的许多权重进行了重新训练，将其降至每个参数 4 位或 8 位。这些模型拥有数十亿个参数，我认为大多数大约有 120 亿个参数，对吧？所以你谈论的是内存的大幅减少，然后只需在你的 CPU 上运行它们。现在，虽然这是一种加速的处理方式，但好的一点是，通常情况下，你的系统内存要大得多，
in your system RAM, just normal sort of like DDR4 RAM or whatever, you know, tied to your main CPU than you do on your GPU. So most people would not be surprised to hear 32 gigabytes or 64 gigabytes or even more of system RAM, but GPU RAM, you're probably, you know, 24 gigabytes would be really big, even 12 gigabytes is sort of large. And so a lot of people don't have a GPU is big enough to do this, but they do have CPUs. And so if you're
in your system RAM, just normal sort of like DDR4 RAM or whatever, you know, tied to your main CPU than you do on your GPU. So most people would not be surprised to hear 32 gigabytes or 64 gigabytes or even more of system RAM, but GPU RAM, you're probably, you know, 24 gigabytes would be really big, even 12 gigabytes is sort of large. And so a lot of people don't have a GPU is big enough to do this, but they do have CPUs. And so if you're|||比如普通的 DDR4 内存或类似的东西，你知道的，与你的主 CPU 相连的内存，要比你的 GPU 内存大得多。所以大多数人听到 32GB、64GB 甚至更多的系统内存都不会感到惊讶，但说到 GPU 内存，你知道的，24GB 就已经非常大了，甚至 12GB 都算挺大的了。因此，许多人并没有大到足以完成这项任务的 GPU，但他们确实有 CPU。所以如果你
willing to lose some performance due to the quantization, although not as much as I was expecting, when you say I'm going to use four bits per parameter, I assumed all this thing's going to be just degenerate, but that's not true. It actually retains a lot of its functionality, which is fascinating.
willing to lose some performance due to the quantization, although not as much as I was expecting, when you say I'm going to use four bits per parameter, I assumed all this thing's going to be just degenerate, but that's not true. It actually retains a lot of its functionality, which is fascinating.|||愿意为了量化而牺牲一些性能（尽管没有我预期得那么多——当你 M 称我要为每个参数使用 4 位时，我以为这东西会彻底退化，但事实并非如此。它实际上保留了大部分功能，这太迷人了。
Yeah, definitely. Yeah, then you can do it on your CPU. And the token speed, sort of the amount of tokenization that occurs is still you know kind of only like maybe one per second or that kind of thing um so not enough for sort of like that interactive chat feeling exactly but also not bad for not having to go out and buy you know a thousand dollar gpu uh and power supplies and everything to go with it yeah this is amazing super exciting um uh yeah i think it's uh it's really cool there's there's a
Yeah, definitely. Yeah, then you can do it on your CPU. And the token speed, sort of the amount of tokenization that occurs is still you know kind of only like maybe one per second or that kind of thing um so not enough for sort of like that interactive chat feeling exactly but also not bad for not having to go out and buy you know a thousand dollar gpu uh and power supplies and everything to go with it yeah this is amazing super exciting um uh yeah i think it's uh it's really cool there's there's a|||是的，绝对的。是的，然后你就可以在你的 CPU 上运行它了。而且 Token 生成速度，也就是进行 Token 化的速率，你知道的，仍然大约只有每秒一个 Token 左右，诸如此类。所以，嗯，这不足以带来那种真正的互动聊天体验，但也算不错了，毕竟你不需要出门去买一块上千美元的 GPU 以及与之配套的电源等各种设备。是的，这太棒了，超级令人兴奋。嗯，是的，我觉得这……这真的很酷。这有一个……
um there's a ton of of uh like uh posts about this and yeah the four-bit quantization pretty uh is pretty impressive i thought that you know with just what 16 numbers to represent each weight that you would have lost something really important but sure but yeah it uh it works really well um yeah i actually have with the four bit quantization i have a llama with seven billion parameters that runs real time on my phone oh yeah that's cool yeah there's an app called mlc chat this is for android i'm not sure if they have it for ios but you can run mlc you can install mlc chat and then you get a 7 billion parameter model right there on your phone it doesn't go to the internet or anything it's pretty remarkable and it um it will definitely hallucinate i asked it, what was the capital of Sri Lanka? And it made up a town. It might be another town, but it's not the capital. So it'll definitely hallucinate. You have to be careful. But I asked it how much Pittsburgh Pirates baseball tickets cost, and it nailed it. So, I mean, these are like pretty esoteric questions.
um there's a ton of of uh like uh posts about this and yeah the four-bit quantization pretty uh is pretty impressive i thought that you know with just what 16 numbers to represent each weight that you would have lost something really important but sure but yeah it uh it works really well um yeah i actually have with the four bit quantization i have a llama with seven billion parameters that runs real time on my phone oh yeah that's cool yeah there's an app called mlc chat this is for android i'm not sure if they have it for ios but you can run mlc you can install mlc chat and then you get a 7 billion parameter model right there on your phone it doesn't go to the internet or anything it's pretty remarkable and it um it will definitely hallucinate i asked it, what was the capital of Sri Lanka? And it made up a town. It might be another town, but it's not the capital. So it'll definitely hallucinate. You have to be careful. But I asked it how much Pittsburgh Pirates baseball tickets cost, and it nailed it. So, I mean, these are like pretty esoteric questions.|||嗯，有很多关于这方面的帖子。是的，4 位量化相当……相当令人印象深刻。我本以为，你知道，仅仅用 16 个数字（译者注：原文指 4-bit 可以表示 16 种状态）来表示每个权重，你会丢失一些非常重要的东西，但确实……但是的，它运行得非常好。嗯，是的，实际上通过 4 位量化，我有一个拥有 70 亿参数的 Llama 模型，它可以在我的手机上实时运行。哦，太酷了。是的，有一个应用叫 MLC Chat，这是针对 Android 的，我不确定他们是否有 iOS 版本，但你可以运行 MLC，你可以安装 MLC Chat，然后你就能在手机上直接拥有一个 70 亿参数的模型。它不会连接互联网或任何东西，这非常了不起。而且它……它肯定会产生幻觉。我问它：“斯里兰卡的首都 是什么？”它胡编了一个城镇。那可能是另一个城镇，但绝对不是首都。所以它肯定会产生幻觉。你必须小心。但我问它匹兹堡海盗队棒球门票多少钱时，它答对了。所以，我的意思是，这些都是相当冷门的问题。
You basically have the power of a Google on mushrooms on your phone. And so it's pretty amazing. The thing that's interesting, I guess, is if you, someone was having this debate like, oh, if you're going to be stranded on a desert island is it better to would you take a usb stick with is a terrible question but usb stick for survival of like chat gpt and what it knows and doesn't know or a compressed wikipedia oh interesting probably probably chat gpt right what do you think i i don't i mean right now probably wikipedia but given like if we sort of assume things continue to improve i i think that
You basically have the power of a Google on mushrooms on your phone. And so it's pretty amazing. The thing that's interesting, I guess, is if you, someone was having this debate like, oh, if you're going to be stranded on a desert island is it better to would you take a usb stick with is a terrible question but usb stick for survival of like chat gpt and what it knows and doesn't know or a compressed wikipedia oh interesting probably probably chat gpt right what do you think i i don't i mean right now probably wikipedia but given like if we sort of assume things continue to improve i i think that|||你基本上在手机上拥有了一个服用迷幻药的 Google 的力量。所以这相当惊人。我想有趣的是，如果你——有人在讨论这样一个辩论：哦，如果你被困在荒岛上，是带一个包含 ChatGPT 及其已知和未知事物的生存 U 盘更好（这是一个糟糕的问题），还是带一个压缩版的维基百科？哦，有趣。大概……大概是 ChatGPT 吧？你觉得呢？我不知道——我的意思是，现在大概是维基百科，但考虑到——如果我们假设事情继续改进，我想
might start to change well actually the wikipedia one would you get a search engine too or do you have to like i think so i think oh okay that's kind of a game changer okay yes i'd probably go wikipedia but i think the interesting thing is chat gpt would potentially know how to surface in a more interactive queryable manner or even distill something so you know we were talking about you're talking about normalizing flows right and some some stuff if i had questions about this going to wikipedia might quickly go over my head and it's going to take me a very very very long time to get to where i need to be to understand versus you know chat gpt could synthesize that down for me and potentially explain it the problem like you mentioned is right now it's sort of not self-aware of when it's hallucinating and so you could potentially end up getting an answer that it's very confident but very wrong yeah i also don't know if you
might start to change well actually the wikipedia one would you get a search engine too or do you have to like i think so i think oh okay that's kind of a game changer okay yes i'd probably go wikipedia but i think the interesting thing is chat gpt would potentially know how to surface in a more interactive queryable manner or even distill something so you know we were talking about you're talking about normalizing flows right and some some stuff if i had questions about this going to wikipedia might quickly go over my head and it's going to take me a very very very long time to get to where i need to be to understand versus you know chat gpt could synthesize that down for me and potentially explain it the problem like you mentioned is right now it's sort of not self-aware of when it's hallucinating and so you could potentially end up getting an answer that it's very confident but very wrong yeah i also don't know if you|||情况可能会开始改变。嗯，实际上对于维基百科那个选项，你也会附带一个搜索引擎吗，还是你必须像……我想是的，我想。哦，好吧，那这有点改变游戏规则了。好吧，是的，我可能会选维基百科。但我认为有趣的是，ChatGPT 可能会知道如何以更具互动性、可查询的方式呈现信息，甚至提炼出某些内容。所以，你知道，我们之前在谈论——你在谈论归一化 flow（归一化流），对吧，还有一些其他东西——如果我对这些有疑问，去查维基百科可能会很快把我整懵，而且要达到我需要理解的水平，会花掉我非常非常非常长的时间；相比之下，你知道，ChatGPT 可以为我综合这些信息并潜在地解释它。正如你所提到的，问题在于目前它在产生幻觉时并没有自我意识，所以你最终可能会得到一个它表现得非常自信但实际上大错特错的答案。是的，我也不知道如果你
described something right like if i described a coconut to chat gpt maybe it would be able to tell me it's a coconut it would be very difficult to query wikipedia for finding out you know is this what is this thing i found on my desert island and can i eat it yeah i mean i was thinking about um building a device like this my idea was basically a flashlight that had um an open source large language model and uh speech to text and text to speech so it's like you could hold the record button and say you know is this tree with four leaves poison ivy and then it would say something back to you that that is really cool although you could also use it to start a fire with the heat it generates so you know like perform two two roles oh man um all right so actually uh my news is also related to LLMs. It's this cool website called chat.lmsys.org. And you can go there, you can ask questions to a variety of different open source, large language models, and you can even ask questions to multiple at a time and see what the different answers are like
described something right like if i described a coconut to chat gpt maybe it would be able to tell me it's a coconut it would be very difficult to query wikipedia for finding out you know is this what is this thing i found on my desert island and can i eat it yeah i mean i was thinking about um building a device like this my idea was basically a flashlight that had um an open source large language model and uh speech to text and text to speech so it's like you could hold the record button and say you know is this tree with four leaves poison ivy and then it would say something back to you that that is really cool although you could also use it to start a fire with the heat it generates so you know like perform two two roles oh man um all right so actually uh my news is also related to LLMs. It's this cool website called chat.lmsys.org. And you can go there, you can ask questions to a variety of different open source, large language models, and you can even ask questions to multiple at a time and see what the different answers are like|||描述了某种东西，对吧——比如如果我向 ChatGPT 描述一个椰子，也许它能告诉我那是椰子。但要通过查询维基百科来弄清楚“我在荒岛上发现的这个东西是什么，我能吃它吗”，将会非常困难。嗯，我是说，我曾考虑过……嗯，构建这样一种设备。我的想法基本上是一个手电筒，它内置了一个开源大语言模型、语音转文本以及文本转语音功能。所以就像你可以按住录音按钮说：“你知道，这棵长着四片叶子的树是毒常春藤吗？”然后它会向你反馈一些信息……这真的很酷，虽然你也可以用它产生的热量来生火，所以你知道，它能发挥两个作用。天哪，嗯。好吧，实际上，我的新闻也与大语言模型有关。这是一个很酷的网站，叫做 chat.lmsys.org。你可以访问那里，向各种不同的开源大语言模型提问，你甚至可以同时向多个模型提问，看看它们的回答在光谱上有什么不同，
on the spectrum there. So I typed in to the 13 billion Lama two model, what are normalizing flows? And it nailed it. It said normalizing flows are a type of generative model. They use a series of invertible transformations to model the distribution of the data. And it,
on the spectrum there. So I typed in to the 13 billion Lama two model, what are normalizing flows? And it nailed it. It said normalizing flows are a type of generative model. They use a series of invertible transformations to model the distribution of the data. And it,|||在那里。所以我向 130 亿参数的 Llama 2 模型输入了这个问题：“什么是归一化流？”它答得太棒了。它说，归一化流是一种生成模型。它们使用一系列可逆变换来对数据的分布进行建模。并且，
it went into the different types of flows um it doesn't talk about radial flows which are the most popular so it missed out it listed four flows but in my opinion missed out on the most important flow um so you know in general i think that you know that's kind of in line with what you'd expect where like some of the details are kind of hazy, but it gets the overall idea, right? Um, yeah, I mean, this thing nailed it. It explains why it needs to be invertible. Um, really impressive.
it went into the different types of flows um it doesn't talk about radial flows which are the most popular so it missed out it listed four flows but in my opinion missed out on the most important flow um so you know in general i think that you know that's kind of in line with what you'd expect where like some of the details are kind of hazy, but it gets the overall idea, right? Um, yeah, I mean, this thing nailed it. It explains why it needs to be invertible. Um, really impressive.|||它详细介绍了不同类型的流。嗯，它没有谈到径向流（radial flows），而径向流是最受欢迎的，所以它漏掉了。它列出了四种流，但在我看来漏掉了最重要的流。嗯，所以你知道，总的来说，我认为这符合你的预期，即某些细节有点模糊，但它抓住了整体概念，对吧？嗯，是的，我是说，这东西答得太准了。它解释了为什么它需要是可逆的。嗯，真的很令人印象深刻。
Um, so yeah, check this out. If, uh, um, if you, if you haven't really been able to access open source models it seemed like it's kind of too far from reach technically um this is a super easy website you literally just click and it's basically the chat gpt interface but for open source models and so you know you can play around with this it's using someone else's compute so it's totally free maybe at some point you'll get rate limited. I haven't tried that. I haven't gotten there yet.
Um, so yeah, check this out. If, uh, um, if you, if you haven't really been able to access open source models it seemed like it's kind of too far from reach technically this is a super easy website you literally just click and it's basically the chat gpt interface but for open source models and so you know you can play around with this it's using someone else's compute so it's totally free maybe at some point you'll get rate limited. I haven't tried that. I haven't gotten there yet.|||嗯，所以是的，去看看这个吧。如果，呃，如果你一直无法真正接触到开源模型，觉得它在技术上似乎遥不可及，这是一个超级简单的网站，你 literalmente（字面意思）只需点一下，它基本上就是 ChatGPT 的界面，但针对的是开源模型。所以，你知道的，你可以试玩一下，它使用的是别人的算力，所以完全免费。也许在某个时候你会遇到速率限制。我还没试过那个。我还没遇到过这种情况。
But you can just play around with this. And if it solves something for you, then that could justify taking the time and energy to get one of these running on your own computer. Also, this LMSYS is all open source. So you can actually clone this repository and make your own version of this where on your computer,
But you can just play around with this. And if it solves something for you, then that could justify taking the time and energy to get one of these running on your own computer. Also, this LMSYS is all open source. So you can actually clone this repository and make your own version of this where on your computer,|||但你可以随便玩玩它。如果它为你解决了某些问题，那么这就足以证明花时间和精力在你自己电脑上运行这样一个模型是值得的。此外，这个 LMSYS 完全是开源的。所以你实际上可以克隆这个代码库，制作你自己的版本，在你的电脑上运行，
you can ask yourself questions or your hardware questions. So you could go from this chat GBT interface to something running on your own hardware, which is pretty exciting um i've i've talked to folks who are generating real value with uh chat gbt um chat gbt is so cheap it's really hard to justify you know the the open source models um you know A lot of the folks I talked to are just using ChatGPT. My interactive fiction game, I have a bunch of folks playing it, which is really cool. And even
you can ask yourself questions or your hardware questions. So you could go from this chat GBT interface to something running on your own hardware, which is pretty exciting um i've i've talked to folks who are generating real value with uh chat gbt um chat gbt is so cheap it's really hard to justify you know the the open source models um you know A lot of the folks I talked to are just using ChatGPT. My interactive fiction game, I have a bunch of folks playing it, which is really cool. And even|||你可以问自己问题或你的硬件问题。所以你可以从这个 ChatGPT 界面过渡到在你自己硬件上运行的东西，这相当令人兴奋。嗯，我——我曾和一些利用 ChatGPT 创造真实价值的人聊过。嗯，ChatGPT 太便宜了，以至于很难证明（使用）开源模型的合理性。你知道的，我交谈过的许多人都在直接使用 ChatGPT。我的互动小说游戏有很多人在玩，这真的很酷。甚至
with all the folks playing it, last month, my bill was 57 cents. So it's hard to compete with that. But yeah, I mean, I think for sensitive things or as a curiosity or or for whatever reason if you want to do the open source ones this is a great opportunity to see how they compare and how they how they've been maturing time for book of the show what is your book of the show patrick my book of the show is uh as as uh is adequate for my level of thinking math with bad drawings um by ben so i have not i have not dug all the way into this book i i have this book and uh i i am familiar with some of the writing here and you know i've read a little bit of it but for me having uh you know i'm not a
with all the folks playing it, last month, my bill was 57 cents. So it's hard to compete with that. Yeah, I mean, I think for sensitive things or as a curiosity or or for whatever reason if you want to do the open source ones this is a great opportunity to see how they compare and how they how they've been maturing time for book of the show what is your book of the show patrick my book of the show is uh as as uh is adequate for my level of thinking math with bad drawings um by ben so i have not i have not dug all the way into this book i i have this book and uh i i am familiar with some of the writing here and you know i've read a little bit of it but for me having uh you know i'm not a|||在有这么多人玩的情况下，上个月我的账单是 57 美分。所以很难与这个价格竞争。是的，我是说，我认为对于敏感事情，或者出于好奇心，或者出于任何原因，如果你想尝试开源模型，这是一个绝佳的机会，可以看看它们是如何对比的以及它们是如何成熟的。本期节目图书时间到了。本期推荐的书是什么，帕特里克？我本期推荐的书是——正如——正如符合我的思维水平的——《素描数学》（Math with Bad Drawings），作者是本（Ben）。所以，我还没有——我还没有完全钻研这本书。我有这本书，而且——我熟悉这里的一些文字，你知道的，我读了一点。但对我来说，拥有——你知道的，我不是一个
mathematician by background or by training in fact i did very poorly at it uh spoiler alert for the upcoming topic but i will say that like i do end up having to do a fair bit of math as i think many people in computer science end up at one point or another or you know i guess maybe depending on your your sort of role but i do do a fair bit of math but for me it has to make sense to me and it's useful to find people who at minimum find alternative ways of explaining but i will say find non-academic ways of explaining intuition behind things it is sometimes hard to to sort of explain arbitrary topics via intuition from start to finish but there's a number of people I'm
very happy to, to have found. Um, uh, and we took about one later, but there's like three blue, one Brown is like a YouTube channel we've talked about before, or he does these math explanations, even watching, um, you know, just math videos on YouTube in general that aren't, aren't classes are good, but Ben Orland has written this book and sort of covers a variety of topics. There's several follow-ons in the same thing. One about playing games, one about, uh, sort of, uh, calculus and just sort of some comic just to kind of like keep you engaged, but also just sort of like cheesy illustrations, um, in order to, to sort of help you help you think about it.
And it just vibrates sometimes with how I think about the world. And so, uh, I recommend this book if you're at all curious, if you're a math tourist, I would say, who's just interested in kind of like a light treatment, a popular treatment, I guess, of a lot of these topics, definitely check it out. Very cool. Actually, you sold me on it. I literally just bought it while you were talking. Oh, no. It's going to be a book of the show next time for Jason. It's going to be my book of the show. We were talking about this before the show, how sometimes a lot of the book I'm reading
right now is kind of invalidated because it was Patrick's book of the show like seven years ago or something. But it doesn't mean you shouldn't read it. Definitely go back and and read all of our books of the show a lot of them are real winners um all right my book of the show is uh beyond reading brandon sanderson which we talked about a couple episodes ago um i was playing this text adventure called overboard it's from the people who made 80 Days, which was my book of the show in 2017. This one is interesting. The challenge with interactive fiction is replayability,
right? I mean, clearly, like a book has, you know, very little replayability compared to video games, a regular book. And so interactive fiction, you have to kind of figure out, if you have to create all this content for all these things a person could do, but then they only do one path and then leave it, then a lot of that content might not be explored by most people. So they want you to be able to play the game multiple times. And this one takes an interesting approach where they have a system of achievements. So you play the same game every time.
There are multiple endings, but a lot of the same thing happens. It's deterministic. So if you do the same thing at the same point in time you'll end up with exactly the same ending um but as a way to keep you finding new content they have this system of achievements and the achievements are based on what you have and haven't seen so if you play the game and just coincidentally you get the best possible ending then you'll get an achievement for like kill as many people as possible you know be like the most evil person
possible because you haven't tried that yet um i thought that was really really clever um i feel like um it wasn't executed perfectly because um it's not clear how to get some of these achievements so you see the achievement and maybe you play you don't get the achievement you have to keep trying and trying and while you're trying you're just trying to do random things it didn't do the best job of keeping track of what you've ever done in the past. So, you know, it has some work to do there and execution, but I love the idea. I think this idea of achievements kind of takes interactive fiction and makes it more like a roguelike where, you know,
you start the game with like advantages the more time you play it. So I think there's something really powerful there on the game design front. And I had a lot of fun it's a good story and so uh um let me just check really quickly what it costs um i can't see what it costs because i already own it um but yeah it's probably like five bucks totally worth it um uh highly recommended it 649 definitely it's worth you you'll easily get a few hours of entertainment minimum out of it so and if you don't want to uh buy that game uh you can uh actually buying that game doesn't support us because it's not an amazon book but if you don't want to buy the math with bad drawings book,
like I just did, you can also support us on Patreon. So if you go to patreon.com slash programming throwdown, big shout out to our supporters. We have had an influx of supporters, which is really cool. I wonder if that's companies forcing people back in the office something to do with that. I don't know. If you are forced back into the office and that caused you to support us on Patreon, we lament the fact that you're forced to go back in, but we really do appreciate the support. All of that money goes in an account, which we use for the show. We don't really pocket we don't actually literally don't pocket any of it we use it to try to bring more people uh into the show and spread the word
so we really appreciate every every dollar of support that we get there and with that we'll go oh go ahead patrick oh no just saying thanks you go ahead oh yeah thanks thanks everyone out there we'll go to tool of the show um why don't you go first okay mine is a website uh ff improviser uh good luck trying to google that you could just but this is it that's not even the full website this is a github link to a sort of interactive website with i guess what you call, almost FFmpeg one-liners. So I've had FFmpeg as my tool of the show before Jason did. One of us did. Super powerful tool.
Horrible command line interface. I'm sure it has to be. It probably has to be. I'm not saying I could do better. To be clear, please don't at me. Well, good luck. You can at me. I don't see them.
Yeah, you don't have an at. I didn't know where you would at me at. But anyways, the benefits. Okay, sorry. You can send me a letter if you could no no no don't don't yeah um all right so ffm provisor has a bunch of things you may want to do with ffm peg and gives you sort of one-liners that you can use to combine together and so definitely makes a very powerful tool but hard to use a little easier to use you know helpful um so definitely check it out i also am bumping into this i did see recommendations for a group of similar tools include including some like visual if you ever played with like lab view
like you drop little modules in on like a data flow graph and it'll sort of generate a FFM peg commands for you. So shout out to a bunch of people like out there trying to, you know, make, make ways of a FFM peg easier to use because truly a powerful tool. I mean, it's used all over the place. This is really awesome.
Video and video codecs are insane. I, I, I still like don't even profess to understand what any of them do or are or the difference between container versus you know i'm not even gonna say it anyways so definitely check it out ffmpeg improviser ff improviser uh very useful tool for for helping you because if you're like me uh i yes never remember i have like little read me sprinkle all over the place for places i normally run ffmpeg to try to remind
me of of the command i used last time nice very cool um my tool of the show is um pandas read ODS and read Excel functions. So I know that's kind of really specific. We have talked about pandas, but it's been probably, I think it was 2016 when we talked about pandas. Pandas is basically a library for getting data frames in Python. If you've ever used R, you know what a data frame is
if you haven't it's basically very similar to an excel table where you have columns each column has a name and a set of values and then you can do arithmetic you can add columns together and stuff Um, and pandas actually can read ODS, which is the, you know, uh, Excel file format for the open, open Excel file format. So you can save a Google sheet to ODS, obviously LibreOffice and OpenOffice read and write ODS. Uh, Excel probably will save ODS as well. Um, pandas can also read Excel files like the XLS and XLSX and all those files. And what Pandas will do is it will actually evaluate all of the formulas,
resolve them to their number. What it won't do is it won't on the fly evaluate the formulas or anything. That's something we talked about at the beginning of the show but but if you have an excel spreadsheet with a bunch of complicated equations and you want to bring that data that output into python you can just read it in one line using pandas which is pretty remarkable so um um so yeah i think there's a uh i think there's a good synergy there um and uh yeah i was really impressed when i found that function that is very cool i yeah the fact that you said it even does like evaluation not just like reading it as columnar data is is pretty cool yeah i'm not sure like oh go ahead i was gonna say i want to make a joke about like VB script and whether it evaluates all the random macros, but.
Oh God, no. You know, I actually don't know if the, I wonder if the file format saves the function and the value, you know what I mean? In the file or if pandas is doing all the calculation. I really don't know i will say i've never written a complex enough equation in my spreadsheets that like i would have been able to tell the difference of whether it was like cached or computed you know sort of like them i i would like when you open the file does it take i guess if you could construct processing complicated enough that it takes literal minutes to sort of finish computing
your spreadsheet in which case it would make sense that they write the value out as well right as a cache oh yeah but so it'd be easy enough to test i've just never written such spreadsheets myself so you know my guess is it probably has the cache value because otherwise the pandas people would have to implement whatever library they use, would have to implement like every Excel function and test it to make sure you got exactly the same answer. It's probably one of those things, you know, it's almost non-existent, the number of Excel files with a lot of the very random esoteric functions. So it's like, do they support 99% of the files? Five, nine, six nine six nines like most excel sheets probably don't even have a formula in them yeah it's a good point it's a really good point um but either way
give it a shot um you know take it uh i mean panda is extremely well supported but still i would i would always have like a little degree of caution with something like that because you are going from one language to another yeah there's probably like a decent way to to like force it into a good state even if you have a tail tail spreadsheet right copy the values out or something and you lose the formulas but pandas would still be able to read it yep yeah. Time for differential equations. So we talked about recursive functions scaring new programmers, and now we have something that scares us. I'm actually pretty nervous, dude. I'm shaking right now.
give it a shot um you know take it   i mean panda is extremely well supported but still i would i would always have like a little degree of caution with something like that because you are going from one language to another yeah there's probably like a decent way to to like force it into a good state even if you have a tail tail spreadsheet right copy the values out or something and you lose the formulas but pandas would still be able to read it yep yeah. Time for differential equations. So we talked about recursive functions scaring new programmers, and now we have something that scares us. I'm actually pretty nervous, dude. I'm shaking right now.
So let's start, as we always do, with the motivation. Why people should learn about DiffEQ. So usually when you hear about differential equations, you think about physics or maybe economics. Actually, we'll put economics aside for a minute. You think of like physics or these kind of like signal processing, these kind of things that are really kind of low level, things that interact with the real world through sensors and all of that. But there is a reason why a lot of people, even if you're building, you know, a website or something like that, or you're driving engagement to a website or doing something, you'll need differential equations.
And that is because of this thing called the law of large numbers. Have you heard of the law of large numbers? Not in this context. So normally I think of it in statistics. So I'm excited to see if it's the same or not. It's exactly the same. So the law of large numbers says, if you have a lot of things and you need to reduce those things, like let's look at dice. If you say, I want to throw 17 dice and I want to get the average, right? So you can just keep track of all these numbers and take the average and you're going to get something, right? What if you get to millions of dice or billions of dice you know what can you do what what the law of large numbers says is that if i average and you know a sequence of numbers from a distribution that i'm that that average is going to be centered around some point right and so with dice for example, you know, if you average a lot of die rolls, you'll get something around 3.5.
Right. If you do it enough times, you're going to get around 3.5. Even if like the first 20 times you rolled, you just coincidentally got a one. You know, eventually with enough samples, the odds of that kind of anomaly go infinitely close to zero. And so you will end up with a number around 3.5. And so, you know, if you want to do things like how much time are people spending on my website or how many people a month are visiting my website or maybe a month's bad example, how many people a minute are visiting my website or maybe a month's bad example how many people a minute are visiting my website so anything where you're going to end up with many many many many many samples um you're going to end up probably doing an average but you know taking some kind of estimate of these samples so you're not working with billions of numbers and as soon as you do that, now you have a continuous number. And so if you, if you were thinking about like traffic coming into Google, right, they're not, they're not looking at it in terms of like, okay, I have this exactly this many people and then exactly this
many people. And I'm going to draw some insights. Like, no, they're taking averages and they're looking at sort of trends over those averages and they're constructing some type of differential equation that's saying, look, people are, you know, this metric is going up, this metric is going down. Here's the covariance, which means as one metric changes changes how it varies the other metrics and so based on the velocities of these metrics and the covariance of all of these metrics you can construct a differential equation that shows you like how you think these metrics are going to evolve in the future. Yeah. So looking at the, the, the, oh, I'm going to start saying words we're not supposed to, but anyways, looking at the, the rate at which the people are coming out and then sort of understanding how those change over time. Yep. Yep. Yeah,
exactly. And so, you know, there's many situations where you have what you want to achieve in the next time step, and that is easy to compute. I think the balancing stocks was a great example where it's like, if I have 60% stocks and 40% bonds and I want it to be 50-50, well, then I know what I need to do. I need to sell stocks and buy bonds until I hit 50-50. And so you have your difference from your goal to your current state that's relatively easy. What's hard is sort of keeping that stable so yeah and this is why they pop up in uh if you ever read stuff about controls and control systems so yeah trying to figure out how to turn the steering wheel on your car to get to where you want to go quickly but not overs. And how do you sort of think about computing these
things? Yep. Yeah, exactly. So like, let's say you had, um, so let's say you, you, you know, you, you like in this case, it's clear. It's like, okay, there's a percent. And so if I get 1% of one, it's kind of one less percent to the other. Well, let's say you didn't really know that the stocks and the bonds had to add up to 100%, right? So you might say, well, the stock number is 40%. I need it to be 50%. So I'll buy 10% more stocks, but then you don't have, but then, you know, Oh, you won't, you won't have the exact 10%. So I'll just buy more stocks, but then you buy more stocks and then you overshoot or, or even a better example is, um, you say to yourself, well, my house is 80 degrees. I need it to be 79 degrees. And so, you know, I'm just going to turn the AC on, you know, full blast.
things? Yep. Yeah, exactly. So like, let's say you had, um, so let's say you, you, you, you, you, like in this case, it's clear. It's like, okay, there's a percent. And so if I get 1% of one, it's kind of one less percent to the other. Well, let's say you didn't really know that the stocks and the bonds had to add up to 100%, right? So you might say, well, the stock number is 40%. I need it to be 50%. So I'll buy 10% more stocks, but then you don't have, but then, you know, Oh, you won't, you won't have the exact 10%. So I'll just buy more stocks, but then you buy more stocks and then you overshoot or, or even a better example is, um, you say to yourself, well, my house is 80 degrees. I need it to be 79 degrees. And so, you know, I'm just going to turn the AC on, you know, full blast.
But you do that and then it causes you to overshoot and you have to kind of keep going back and forth. So it turns out that for a lot of these, what you really want is something that is you know pretty stable and oh another part of this is it gets really complicated when things affect other things so for example let's say you have you know air conditioning and humidity but when you run the air conditioner it you know causes your house to become less humid. And so you might have a humidifier, but then the humidifier drops the temperature. And so these things are affecting each other because the differential equation like not long enough to support both of the cars and everything starts like jittering and then spiraling out of control. That's a case where, you know, the game, because, you know, it wants to run in real time, it's going to take, you know, kind of larger steps and it's going to spiral out of control.
So, yeah, we should actually talk a little bit about step sizes. So, you know, in Patrick's example of the stocks, right, you might say like buy 10% more stocks. So let's say you instantly do that. And, you know, Patrick is a billionaire, right? So that's not a small transaction. So that's not a small transaction. So 10% of all of that, let's say that influences the stock market, or even just it's happening at a really volatile time where stocks and bonds are going up and down. It's crazy. You buy that 10%, but you buying that kind of changes the market dynamics. Maybe it makes the price go up. And then also other crazy things are happening. And so you find that, oh, after I did that buy, I'm actually even further from the goal. It's like being bad at mini golf. You're bad at mini golf and you putt and it goes past the hole and then you're even further
from the hole and you putt again and it's just getting worse. So one way to do that is to say, well, here's what I'm going to do. I'm going to buy one share of a stock or a bond. Let's say buy one share. It's going to get me a little closer to 50-50. And then I'll measure again. It's like, okay, now I'm at 40.1% stock bonds. So I'll buy one more bond. I'm at 40.2%. I'll buy one more bond. And so you could do that and you'll eventually get equilibrium and it'll be stable, but it will take forever. Right? right and so that's the paradox is if you go really slowly then then uh it takes a ton of either compute or time or what have you um if you go quickly then you can cause like second order multi-order effects um and there's an example i have that folks should check out um in the fun example section at the bottom it's predator prey relationships so the idea there is um basically you know every fox
eats one deer um and deer multiply at a certain rate and uh the question is you know how do you end up with something stable so if you have 20 foxes and 20 deer and you take one full step, well, what happens? All 20 foxes eat all 20 deer and then all the foxes die because all the deer are gone. Right. So you can't just take one full step or it just destroys itself. Right. So you could take baby steps and say, OK again i'm going to do this i'm going to assume that because these law of large numbers of this these 20 foxes are actually you know 20
eats one deer   and deer multiply at a certain rate and uh the question is you know how do you end up with something stable so if you have 20 foxes and 20 deer and you take one full step, well, what happens? All 20 foxes eat all 20 deer and then all the foxes die because all the deer are gone. Right. So you can't just take one full step or it just destroys itself. Right. So you could take baby steps and say, OK again i'm going to do this i'm going to assume that because these law of large numbers of this these 20 foxes are actually you know 20
million foxes and so i can kind of divide them into smaller and smaller numbers and so you know the the 20 foxes start eating more deer but they don't all eat a whole deer there's just tiny micro changes and the deer population starts tanking and then that means the fox uh population starts dropping because they start starving and that allows the deer population to recover and then you get this sort of like harmonic situation and um you know basically you can see from this this site like based on the step size either you know all foxes eat all deer and then they all die or you get this like oscillation thing or uh with a small enough step size it kind of converges to some equilibrium where enough foxes are eating just enough deer to match the growth rate of the deer and it's all
kind of exact. And if you had started with that end state, it would be an equilibrium and you could set the step size to anything and it would just stick there. But because you started from a state that wasn't an equilibrium, the step size size really starts to matter does that make sense yeah totally and i think this is part of the the sort of modeling setup and the iterative nature of a lot of these things and and sort of running them forward and you already kind of mentioning but simulations where you you hear about this a lot and thinking about the the consequences of what you're doing and and how to simulate these things um i think with like what you're saying i tend to think of a more like discrete way right like oh you could have like the foxes be in cells and the deers i think there were foxes and deers
be in other cells um and then like having them move around and that is one way of doing it but i guess you call it more like an agent simulation but that's is one way of doing it but i guess you call it more like an agent simulation but that's the only way to do it you don't actually need to model any individuals where you're kind of saying by the law of large numbers you don't need to actually model any individual deer or any individual predator like it you could just model it at scale and talk about the full thing where doing an agent-based simulation actually would run into a lot of problems so they're sort of treating the problem with uh different approaches yep yeah exactly and so you know a lot of biologists i mean definitely biologists like the 1900 or 1800s and stuff you know they couldn't do the simulation and so they had to rely on these really coarse things where
be in other cells   and then like having them move around and that is one way of doing it but i guess you call it more like an agent simulation but that's is one way of doing it but i guess you call it more like an agent simulation but that's the only way to do it you don't actually need to model any individuals where you're kind of saying by the law of large numbers you don't need to actually model any individual deer or any individual predator like it you could just model it at scale and talk about the full thing where doing an agent-based simulation actually would run into a lot of problems so they're sort of treating the problem with uh different approaches yep yeah exactly and so you know a lot of biologists i mean definitely biologists like the 1900 or 1800s and stuff you know they couldn't do the simulation and so they had to rely on these really coarse things where
they'd have people go out and like you know count the number of foxes in like a whole county and then, uh, do that a few times until they can get some kind of statistical average. You know, they could use the law of large numbers, even if they don't have a lot of numbers. Right. And so just tolerate some kind of error there and then, and then move into differential equations. Um, so yeah so i think um okay yeah so we'll dive into um you you'll hear the word ordinary differential equations and partial differential equations so so if you look at like the fox example you know the fox the number of foxes affected by the number of deers and and vice versa and all of that um but you don't really care about modeling it in those dimensions the only dimension you really care about is time
they'd have people go out and like you know count the number of foxes in like a whole county and then, uh, do that a few times until they can get some kind of statistical average. You know, they could use the law of large numbers, even if they don't have a lot of numbers. Right. And so just tolerate some kind of error there and then, and then move into differential equations. Um, so yeah so i think um okay yeah so we'll dive into um you you'll hear the word ordinary differential equations and partial differential equations so so if you look at like the fox example you know the fox the number of foxes affected by the number of deers and and vice versa and all of that   but you don't really care about modeling it in those dimensions the only dimension you really care about is time
so it's like you know what is going to happen in the future? So, you know, if F is number of foxes, D is number of deer and time is T, you know, T is the only one you're exploring. Now F and D are changing as you, you know, move through time, but you're not moving through the number of foxes. You know, you, you set an initial value and then you move through time. And so what that means is you're only differentiating through time. So that's where partial differential equation comes from. The equation has many different variables, but you're only interested in a part of them for the purpose of differentiating. And so if you're only differentiating through one variable, and there's maybe some other conditions too, then you have an ordinary
differential equation. And if you have an ODE, then a whole bunch of techniques open up to you. Another thing about, I think, ordinary differential equation is there's no discontinuities so this is this is again a really uh point that folks can get stuck on right they might say well you know i might have some if statement that says well like if i'm in a certain case then the foxes eat the deer otherwise the foxes don't eat the deer. And so there's this break, right? There's some variable that's like binary, right? And if you do that, then all of these techniques aren't going to work. And so that might sound really limiting.
differential equation. And if you have an ODE, then a whole bunch of techniques open up to you. Another thing about, I think, ordinary differential equation is there's no discontinuities so this is this is again a really   uh point that folks can get stuck on right they might say well you know i might have some if statement that says well like if i'm in a certain case then the foxes eat the deer otherwise the foxes don't eat the deer. And so there's this break, right? There's some variable that's like binary, right? And if you do that, then all of these techniques aren't going to work. And so that might sound really limiting.
But again, when you start looking at really large numbers, you should kind of expect everything to have some inertia right you shouldn't expect there to be like these really sharp discontinuities just like you know you wouldn't expect like everyone to leave google tomorrow like it's just not not really reasonable like even if google like somehow uh uh the whole page is full of ads tomorrow or something made some kind of really bad product decision there'd still be like this decay right so um so you know at this scale you know a lot of those constraints are pretty manageable and um um and so once you have an ordinary differential equation then there's a whole bunch of interesting things that pop up. Um, you know, in the way that we were talking about solving, you know, Patrick's balancing stock balancing issue, we were using
But again, when you start looking at really large numbers, you should kind of expect everything to have some inertia right you shouldn't expect there to be like these really sharp discontinuities just like you know you wouldn't expect like everyone to leave google tomorrow like it's just not not really reasonable like even if google like somehow   uh   the whole page is full of ads tomorrow or something made some kind of really bad product decision there'd still be like this decay right so   um   so you know at this scale you know a lot of those constraints are pretty manageable and   um   and so once you have an ordinary differential equation then there's a whole bunch of interesting things that pop up. Um, you know, in the way that we were talking about solving,   you know, Patrick's balancing stock balancing issue, we were using
Euler's method. We were basically saying, you know, we know how to get exactly to the goal, but we know that if we took that big step that, um, you know, it would cause some disruption and it would move the goalpost and we would be in trouble. So we'll take baby steps. And at each step, we'll reevaluate the distance to the goal. Another good example of this is missile tracking. So if there's a target and you have a missile, you're playing some kind of video game or something. The missile might say like, oh, my target's here.
Euler's method. We were basically saying, you know, we know how to get exactly to the goal, but we know that if we took that big step that,   um, you know, it would cause some disruption and it would move the goalpost and we would be in trouble. So we'll take baby steps. And at each step, we'll reevaluate the distance to the goal. Another good example of this is missile tracking. So if there's a target and you have a missile, you're playing some kind of video game or something. The missile might say like, oh, my target's here.
I need to draw like this arrow. Like I need to go in this direction. But then, you know, the target's moving. So as the missile is going to the target, the target's also moving. And so, you know, the missile would end up kind of curving towards it if, if it didn't have any predictive capability. Right. Um, and so that's, that's another example of a differential equation.
I need to draw like this arrow. Like I need to go in this direction. But then, you know, the target's moving. So as the missile is going to the target, the target's also moving. And so, you know, the missile would end up kind of curving towards it if, if it didn't have any predictive capability. Right.   Um, and so that's, that's another example of a differential equation.
Um, oh yeah. So, so Euler is a first order method. Um, there's also like second, third, fourth order methods. And what these do is they look at a series of predictions and they use a series of these to get an even more accurate step. Um, so for example, um, this is using the mini golf example let's say you overshot the hole and uh um you kind of learn to yourself like okay you know i need to hit it a little less hard next time right so even though like maybe you overshot the hole and you're twice as far as you were last time you kind of learned okay i need to hit it twice as hard but also a little bit less because i clearly hit it too hard this time let's say you hit it and you hit it you know 1.5 times as hard and you still overshot the hole so you kind of learned like okay i need to hit it even less than
Um, oh yeah. So, so Euler is a first order method. Um, there's also like second, third, fourth order methods. And what these do is they look at a series of predictions and they use a series of these to get an even more accurate step.   Um, so for example,   um, this is using the mini golf example let's say you overshot the hole and   uh   um you kind of learn to yourself like okay you know i need to hit it a little less hard next time right so even though like maybe you overshot the hole and you're twice as far as you were last time you kind of learned okay i need to hit it twice as hard but also a little bit less because i clearly hit it too hard this time let's say you hit it and you hit it you know 1.5 times as hard and you still overshot the hole so you kind of learned like okay i need to hit it even less than
that and so with these other multi-order methods you can take bigger steps towards the goal and still have less of this overshooting problem because it's taking more information into account we were been talking about i guess like controls and like controlling things or taking action but i think we also see them pop up in sort of running physics engines and games and to me there it's a little different you're attempting to model the setup of the differential equations like the force of gravity on a ball falling down in your video game and there you're trying to say i'm actually wanting to compute position by given an arbitrary time so i'm going to give you some time in the future which is you know my game last displayed here and i've moved x
time step forward and setting up your equation so that instead of defining that step in advance you can compute the position at an arbitrary time into the future. And so there, I think to your point, you're sort of changing the situation a bit rather than what action am I going to take? You're sort of giving the system, hey, here's a new time. Can you tell me what all the positions are now? Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, actually, it's a really good example. Like imagine if you have a ball that's moving towards a wall, you might say to yourself, like, this is a pretty simple situation. And I could take a pretty big step. In fact, if there's nothing around, maybe I take such a big step that the ball hits the wall. And I don't have to think about anything in between. So, so, you know, just maybe the ball is so far from any other object that you just say, look, for the next three seconds, this ball is going to arc and it's going to bounce off the wall and I can come back three seconds later. I don't have to do any math at all. Um, conversely,
时间前进一步并建立你的方程，这样你就不用提前定义那个步骤，而是可以计算未来任意时间点的职位。所以在这里，我觉得正如你所说，你其实是稍微改变了一下情况，而不是问我要采取什么行动？你有点像是在给系统一个新的时间。你能告诉我现在的各个位置都在哪吗？是的，这说得通。对，实际上，这是一个非常好的例子。就像想象一下，如果你有一个球正朝一面墙移动，你可能会对自己说，这其实是一个相当简单的情况。我可以迈出一大步。事实上，如果周围什么都没有，也许我会迈出这么大的一步，以至于球直接撞到了墙上。而我完全不需要考虑中间发生的任何事。所以，你知道，可能球距离任何其他物体都足够远，以至于你会说，看吧，在接下来的三秒钟里，这个球会划出一个弧线，然后从墙上弹开，我三秒钟后再回来就行了。我根本不需要做任何数学计算。相反，
like maybe the ball is chained to another ball and both of those balls are now like, you know, moving through the air air but in weird ways where they're kind of pulling on each other right well that is a really unstable and uh and so you might need a really low time step and all these physics engines do kind of dynamic time stepping and stuff like that but you know using a multi-order method is even better um if you can afford it so the equations are more complicated i thought you were gonna you said two things i thought you're gonna do three and we're gonna talk about the three body problem um but no you avoided that but i mean just to reference that i mean i think one of the things you'll see pop up when you're
就像可能这个球被链条拴在另一个球上，而这两个球现在都在空中以某种奇怪的方式移动，它们互相拉扯，对吧？好吧，那真的是一个很不稳定的情况，因此你可能需要一个非常小的步长，所有的这些物理引擎其实都会做那种动态步长调整之类的东西，但你知道，使用更高阶的方法甚至会更好，如果你负担得起的话，这样方程会更复杂。我以为你会说两件事，我以为你会说三件，然后我们要讨论三体问题，但没有，你避开了这个，不过我的意思是，仅仅提及这一点，我认为你会发现的一件事是当你
you're talking about differential equations is if you think about, as Jason was mentioning, things interact with each other. So it's not just, you know, one object moving through the world without consequences. If you think about in space, if you think about two planets or two massive objects or low mass, anyways, it doesn't matter. Think about two things in space near each other. They are pulling on each other gravitationally. There's a force right so this is like you are trying to understand why does the moon orbit the earth but
在讨论微分方程时，如果你去思考，正如杰森所提到的，事物之间是会互相影响的。所以它不只是一个物体在世界上毫无后果地移动。如果你想想太空中，如果你想想两颗行星，或者两个大质量物体，或者小质量，总之，这不重要。想想太空中靠近彼此的两个东西。它们在引力作用下相互吸引。存在一个力，对吧？所以这就像是，你想要理解为什么月亮绕着地球转，但
the earth moon together also orbit the sun um and so if you sort of think about the interactions of these as they play out and fast forwarding through and understanding where they're going to be at some time point it it depending on the level of precision you care about yeah the moon is way smaller than the earth but it does actually cause the earth's orbit to wobble around as it spins around it's pulling on earth just as earth is pulling on it which is um you know you'll see things like oh we are predicting that there's a planet that we can't see because there's these slight disturbances in another orbit of a planet, you know, as something is passing by and they pull on each other. And, you know, that is sort of a continuous thing. And it doesn't matter how small or big it is.
地球和月亮一起也绕着太阳转，所以如果你去思考这些相互作用在它们上演时的过程，并快进到它们在某个时间点的位置，这取决于你关心的精度水平。是的，月亮比地球小得多，但它其实确实会导致地球的轨道在它旋转时发生晃动，它在拉扯地球，就像地球在拉扯它一样，这就是为什么你会看到诸如“哦，我们预测有一个我们看不见的行星，因为另一个行星的轨道上有这些微小的扰动”，你知道的，当有什么东西经过并且它们互相拉扯时。你知道，这是一种持续存在的现象。而且不管它有多小或多大都一样。
Now, at some point, you probably just don't care about it anymore, right? You know, a baseball space debris floating around the Earth has an influence on its orbit, but it's such a degree you're probably going to ignore but as you sort of try to account for more and more of these at you know increasing levels of position a precision uh you know imagine trying to launch a space vehicle to meet up with mars and make a precision landing right you need to be able to solve these differential equations in a very precise manner as jason's pointing out like allowing to layer on more and more uh you know ways of increasing the accuracy and precision because you really care you really want to know the exact moment that the two things are going to
现在，在某种程度上，你可能只是不再关心它了，对吧？你知道，漂浮在地球周围的棒球太空碎片对它的轨道有影响，但这种影响小到你可能会忽略它。但当你试图解释越来越多的这些影响时，在不断提高的精度水平下，你知道的，想象一下试图发射一个太空飞行器去与火星会合并进行精确着陆，对吧？你需要能够以非常精确的方式求解这些微分方程，正如杰森所指出的，允许一层又一层地增加准确性和精度的途径，因为你真的很在乎，你真的想知道这两者将在什么时候
meet up because it has a range of consequences including how much fuel you put on your rocket and how much fuel you put on your rocket determines how much velocity it's going to have and it's a it's a cascade of things. And you need a setup that allows you to iteratively converge on a solution. Yeah, totally. Totally, totally. Yeah, I mean, there's so many things where when you start modeling at a high level, you run headfirst in differential equations.
相遇的准确时刻，因为这有一系列后果，包括你在火箭里放多少燃料，而你在火箭里放多少燃料决定了它将拥有多大的速度，这是一个连环反应。你需要一个能够让你通过迭代收敛到一个解决方案的设置。是的，完全同意。完全，完全。是的，我是说，有太多的事情，当你开始在一个高水平上进行建模时，你会一头扎进微分方程里。
Like imagine you're making some some kind of strategy game right so it might be that if you want to know if your game is fair if it's balanced um it might be hard to do that in simulation you know because you have all the different units and they're moving around and and it could be really difficult to think about all the all of that and compute all of that what you could do instead is you know come up with some mathematical models that say okay you know if i have uh so maybe i have a measure of army strength which is just a number that i've learned and i've learned that you know for this configuration of units i have a strength of this for this configuration of units I have a strength of that and I learned some function that says given two army strengths which one wins and maybe what's left of their army after they win
就像想象你在制作某种策略游戏，对吧？所以可能的情况是，如果你想知道你的游戏是否公平、是否平衡，在模拟中做到这一点可能会很困难，你知道的，因为你有所有不同的单位，它们四处移动，考虑所有这些并计算所有这些可能会非常困难。取而代之的是，你可以做的是想出一些数学模型，说，好吧，如果我有，所以也许我有一个军队强度的度量，这只是我学到的一个数字，我了解到对于这种单位配置，我有这样的强度，对于那种单位配置，我有那种强度，我学到了一些函数，它说给定两个军队强度，哪一个会赢，也许还有他们赢了之后军队还剩下什么
uh so given given two army strengths that fight you know what are the army strengths at the end one of them will be zero and the other one will be something um you know now you can construct sort of differential equations that talk about um you know should i you know if i like like what happens to my army strength as a function of the current base yeah am i like how is the army strength growing and subtracting and all of that? And so, you know, once you start abstracting out to kind of a higher level going to be full of partial differential equations. And I bet you even beyond what's in the game, you know, they were tuned and that game was tuned using differential equations solvers. You know, another like more kind of industrial example or commercial example is PageRank. So PageR rank was the algorithm that google used initially to rank all the content on the internet and the way it works is they manually uh give some amount of of
所以给定两个进行战斗的军队强度，最后军队的强度是多少？其中一个会是零，而另一个会是某个值，现在你可以构建一些微分方程来讨论，你知道的，我是否应该，如果我喜欢，我的军队强度作为当前基础的函数会发生什么变化？是的，我的军队强度是如何增长和减少的，诸如此类？所以，一旦你开始抽象到一个更高的水平，就会充满偏微分方程。我敢打赌，甚至在游戏之外，你知道的，它们也是经过调整的，那个游戏就是使用微分方程求解器进行调整的。另一个更具工业性或商业性的例子是 PageRank。所以 PageRank 是谷歌最初用来对互联网上所有内容进行排名的算法，它的工作原理是他们手动给予一定数量的
rank uh think of rank as like a resource right they give some amount of rank to a bunch of websites that they uh code up by hand and then they say when those websites link to a website um some of that rank is diffused onto that website so um so if, uh, you know, um, uh, like msn.com links to some, some, uh, kataku.com and some energy passes from one to the other. And so they used, initially they used Euler's method. So they said, well, we're not going to give just all of MSN's energy to like the first link we see. That would be crazy.
排名，把排名想象成一种资源，对吧？他们把一定数量的排名给予了一堆他们手写的网站，然后他们说，当这些网站链接到一个网站时，一部分排名就会扩散到那个网站上。所以，如果，你知道的，像 msn.com 链接到一些 kataku.com，一些能量就会从一个传到另一个。所以他们最初使用的是欧拉方法。所以他们说，好吧，我们不会把 MSN 的所有能量都给看到的第一个链接。那太疯狂了。
So we're going to look at like roughly how many pages does how many domains is this domain link to and will diffuse some portion of their energy equally to all of those pages. And they're linking to other pages and those pages are linking to other pages and so you have this multi-order effect and so um you have a you have a partial differential equation so as time progresses you know this this rank diffuses through all of these websites until eventually it stabilizes and using um you know differential equations and you know the theory behind that you can compute the page rank you know more or less efficiently while still getting a pretty stable answer and even you know when you're trying to figure out how much rank should i diffuse among the different pages and what's a sort And what's the most fair way to do that? Differential equations will allow you to do that very quickly. So for example, if you were to
所以我们要看看这个域名链接到大约多少个页面或多少个域，并将他们的一部分能量平均扩散到所有这些页面。而它们又链接到其他页面，那些页面又链接到其他页面，所以你会有这种多阶效应，因此你有一个偏微分方程，随着时间的推移，这种排名会通过所有这些网站扩散，直到最终稳定下来，并且通过使用微分方程和背后的理论，你可以或多或少高效地计算出网页排名，同时仍然得到一个相当稳定的答案。甚至，你知道，当你试图弄清楚我应该在不同的页面之间扩散多少排名，什么是某种，最公平的方法是什么？微分方程将允许你非常快地做到这一点。所以例如，如果你
just use Euler's method and compute page rank on the whole internet, maybe that would take days, maybe months. But if you were to use faster methods, you could get the same answer in like two minutes. And so getting it that quickly allows you to do a lot more interesting analysis we haven't yet told people how to actually solve differential equations jason oh man uh yeah that's a really good point i'm teasing i think this has been this has been a great sampler like uh an overlook of the various aspects. And I feel like it's one of those things where, you know, hearing it over audio, I guess maybe some people are out there furiously scribbling notes. But I feel like that's the right way to cover it to give sort of the list of things, the sort of what's the next hop in the journey to learn more about these things, to understand if you've encountered these things and didn't know the right words for it.
仅仅使用欧拉方法并在整个互联网上计算网页排名，这可能需要几天，甚至几个月。但如果你使用更快的方法，你可以在两分钟内得到同样的答案。所以能这么快地得到结果，能让你做更多有趣的分析。我们还没告诉大家如何真正求解微分方程呢，杰森。哦，天哪，是的，这真是个好点子。我在开玩笑，我觉得这是一个很好的精选集，是对各个方面的一个概览。我觉得这是那种事情，你知道的，通过音频听到它，我想也许有些人正拼命记笔记。但我觉得这是涵盖它的正确方式，给出一系列事情，作为进一步了解这些事物的旅程中的下一站，去理解如果你遇到过这些事情却不知道正确的词汇该怎么说。
We were talking about that, right? About Wikipedia versus ChatGPT. How do you sort of find the next thing? So hopefully this has been useful to people. I mean, without going into a very lengthy discussion about how to actually run Euler's method or do some of these things I feel like this has been a great introduction to the topic yeah I think this is one of those categories where you should use software off the internet so sci-fi yeah like
我们之前在讨论这个，对吧？关于维基百科和 ChatGPT。你如何找到下一个话题？所以希望这对大家有用。我是说，在不进行非常冗长的讨论去讲解如何实际运行欧拉方法或做其中某些事情的情况下，我觉得这对于这个主题来说是一个很棒的介绍。是的，我觉得这是那种你应该使用互联网上的软件的类别，所以像 SciPy，对吧？
sci-fi for python is amazing they have like seven different solvers they're all great um um but i would say the first thing you need to do is is come up with a function and you can pick whatever language you want but come up with a function that says given my variables so like using patrick's example you know given my percentage of stocks and bonds you know what is the step like what is the difference i need to make to solve that so in patrick's case you know if he has 40 one 60 the other then the difference is to get it to 50 50 and i guess you know you need the denominator for that but but you know let's say you pass that in it's like oh here's what i could do that would like instantly solve my problem based on what i know right now come up with that function make sure it doesn't have any side effects doesn't
Python 的 SciPy 太棒了，他们有大约七个不同的求解器，它们都非常棒。但我会说你需要做的第一件事是想出这样一个函数，你可以选择任何你想要的语言，但要写出一个函数，它说给定我的变量，所以使用帕特里克的例子，你知道，给定我的股票和债券的比例，什么是步长？也就是为了解决这个问题我需要做出什么改变？所以在帕特里克的情况下，你知道，如果他有 40% 的这个，60% 的那个，那么差距就是把它调整到 50 对 50，我想，你知道，你需要分母来计算这个，但是，你知道，假设你把它传进去，就像，哦，这就是我能做的，它会根据我现在的所知立即解决我的问题。想出那个函数，确保它没有任何副作用，不需要
need to like read from a file or anything it's some pretty small function it doesn't use globals or anything like that um and then you can plug it into a solver and you can actually explore different solvers and see what happens. Cool. Very cool. Yeah, definitely check it out. It's a good, it's an important thing. You will often be in a situation
像从文件中读取数据之类的，它是一个非常小的函数，不使用全局变量或类似的东西，然后你可以把它插入求解器中，你实际上可以探索不同的求解器，看看会发生什么。太酷了。非常酷。是的，一定要去看看。这是一个很好的、重要的事情。你经常会处于这样一种情况
where you know what needs to be done, but then you do it. And as you do it, you change the nature of the system. And it seems like you never really get to the goal. That's what differential equations are really good at fixing. So yeah, check it out. Check out the links. We have a ton of really good content in the show notes. You can go to programmingthrowdown.com or you can look at the show notes tab of your podcast app if you have that available you can also go on our patreon and we have all the show notes there and uh
你知道需要做什么，但当你去做的时候，随着你的进行，你改变了这个系统的性质。而且看起来你似乎永远无法真正达到目标。这就是微分方程非常擅长解决的问题。所以，是的，去看看吧。看看链接。我们的节目简介里有大量非常好的内容。你可以访问 programmingthrowdown.com，或者如果你有可用的播客应用，可以查看播客应用的节目简介标签页，你也可以访问我们的 Patreon，我们在那里有所有的节目简介，还有
and a super fast rss connection over there thank you everyone yeah all right thanks everybody my hurts. How do you feel? Is your brain on fire right now? I guess it's time for me to compute the rate of change of hormones in my brain from neural connections. I need to compute how hard my head hits the pillow. All right, everybody. Hopefully we didn't melt brains. It's a super interesting topic, and we will catch you all next time see you later music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license.
一个超快的 RSS 连接。谢谢大家。好的，谢谢大家。我的头好痛。你感觉怎么样？你的脑子现在着火了吗？我想是时候计算我大脑中荷尔蒙随神经连接的变化率了。我需要计算我的头撞到枕头上的力度有多大。好了，各位。希望我们没有把大家的脑子融化掉。这是一个超级有趣的话题，我们下次节目再见。再见。音乐由 Eric Barn Dollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可协议下发布。
You are free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混编、改编，但你必须对我和帕特里克进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。